Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlove. Hallo und hier ist.
97 unserer Sendereihe und auch heute.
Wird sich das Krisenbegleitprogramm mal wieder um die Ukraine kümmern und heute mache ich das mal wieder mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja es gab viel äh zu tun in der Zwischenzeit äh in anderen Dingen, sodass wir beide uns jetzt hier zur Ukraine erstmal in den letzten sechs Wochen leider nicht unterhalten
aber ich habe ja dann nochmal die Sendung mit Enno eingeschoben, die hast du ja wahrscheinlich auch gehört, richtig?
Ja hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ja, das war halt ein Bericht direkt von vor Ort. In der Zwischenzeit ist Enno tatsächlich schon ein zweites Mal in die Ukraine gereist und auch schon wieder daraus zurückgekehrt.
Ähm aber wir haben jetzt erstmal nicht vor davon nochmal zu berichten ähm sondern jetzt hier erstmal.
Auf unsere altgewohnte Art und Weise ein wenig zusammenzufegen, was denn eigentlich so passiert ist. Sprich, wir wollen uns jetzt so vom zeitlichen Verlauf erstmal,
die hm Ereignisse seit der letzten UKW Sendung, also seit der Sendung mit Enno einreihen und mal so ein bisschen aufzeichnen, was so aus unserer Perspektive
insgesamt passiert ist und was sich derzeit so ereignet beziehungsweise so abzeichnet und wir wollen vor allem nochmal so zwei, drei
äh in Anführungsstrichen Highlights ähm der letzten Wochen auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer besprechen auch äh so ein paar Debatten aufgreifen.
Um Waffenlieferung und generell die Hilfe des Westens et cetera und natürlich ähm versuchen.
Eine Einschätzung zu geben, was unserer Auffassung nach insgesamt, da jetzt grade passiert und noch,
passieren könnte. Aber das vielleicht mal so als Einstieg.
Genau und äh ja und dann vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen genauer äh gucken ähm wie ist denn Deutschlands Hilfe tatsächlich zu,
bewerten und ähm ja äh ist unser Kanzler jetzt
wirklich eine beleidigte Leberwurst oder darf man ihn so nennen? Ähm und dann auch noch die vielleicht nicht ganz uninteressante Frage, gibt's denn jetzt Atomkrieg oder nicht? Äh da gibt's auch ein paar neue Einschätzungen
Äh genau aber zu was ich nochmal sagen wollte zur zur Sendung mit
was ich halt bemerkenswert fand, ist, dass da jemand ist, den ich seit langer Zeit persönlich kenne und vertraue und
ähm sagen, der war da wirklich vor Ort und hat das mit eigenen Augen gesehen, weil ähm das
ja gibt mir dann halt
doch noch mal Vertrauen darin, dass dieser ganze Krieg auch wirklich stattfindet, ja und das nicht nur eine mediale Veranstaltung ist, sondern ähm das gibt nochmal quasi so einen direkten, persönlichen Bezug.
Äh zu den Ereignissen. Also hat mir es jedenfalls gegeben und
auch äh so dann wirklich die Einschätzungen vor Ort, die er die er gegeben hat, wie das da alles läuft, das fand ich halt äh auch alles ganz, ganz interessant äh nach nachzuhören und auch wie äh
Journalismus dort eigentlich funktioniert im im Krieg, also wie Kriegsberichterstattung ähm so eigentlich läuft.
Warum es wichtig ist, einen Pool zu haben in seinem Hotel, wenn man im Krisengebiet ist.
Das hatte ich auch extrem erhellend.
Wegen der Trinkwasserreserven, aber
wir äh gut wir wollen wer will, kann sich den ja auch nochmal dann dann äh nachhören und ich denke auch, obwohl unsere letzte Sendung äh jetzt sechs Wochen her ist,
ist die auch eine, die so ein bisschen, glaube ich, fast zeitlos ist, beziehungsweise habe ich das Gefühl, dass das, was wir dort gesagt haben und unsere Einschätzungen, die wir abgegeben haben, dass das nach wie vor Gültigkeit
hat, dass sich eigentlich die Dinge so entwickeln äh jetzt, wie wir äh das angenommen haben vor sechs Wochen.
Im Groben, ja? Also natürlich nicht im Detail, das äh kann immer keiner so richtig vorhersagen, wie auch und da wollen wir uns jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt auf die Schulter klopfen. Wir sind nur ganz froh, dass wir's vielleicht nicht.
Nicht komplett daneben gelegen haben, wobei es jetzt auch äh schwierig ist, das zusammenzufassen, aber ich würde mal sagen, im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen, der Widerstand der Ukraine,
ist nach wie vor groß. Die Probleme der Russen sind nach wie vor groß,
aber die Probleme, die die Russen in der Ukraine schaffen, sind auch nach wie vor sehr groß und ähm da ist noch lange nichts wirklich gut. Es ist halt.
Nur alles noch nicht so schlimm, wie es theoretisch hätte sein können.
Ja dann lass uns äh doch mal hm auch damit anfangen vielleicht so nach Regionen mh die militärische Lage oder überhaupt die allgemeine Lage ein bisschen zusammenzufassen?
Um mal so einen Blick dafür zu bekommen, was eigentlich grade los ist, weil es
geschieht ja sehr viel an sehr vielen Orten und nicht jede Meldung, die so reinrauscht, ist einem dann sofort klar, wo jetzt etwas ist oder wo etwas einen Impact hat. Also immer, wenn ich irgend so eine,
Twittermeldungen ähm kriege mit, keine Ahnung, die Russen haben jetzt dieses Dorf eingenommen und die äh Ukrainer haben hier äh zurückgeschlagen,
Mein erster Weg äh immer zu Google Earth und dann gucke ich mir das mal an was das jetzt eigentlich genau ist und inwiefern.
Auch so mit den ähm militärischen.
Fortschrittskarten der letzten zwei Tage übereinstimmt, ne? Also weil oft kommen dann Meldungen auch spät und.
Ist das in meinen Augen irgendwie gar keine große Meldung mehr, weil das so Fortschritte sind, die eigentlich schon seit längerem klar sind. Geht da immer so ein bisschen hin und her. Das hilft schon so ein bisschen das einzuschätzen.
Ich würde erstmal ähm.
Nochmal kurz als Rückblick. Also wir hatten ich hatte mit Enno gesprochen. Er war ja da im und das war ja dann der Zeitraum, wo sich die Russen aus dem Norden zurückgezogen haben. Und dieser Rückzug ist.
Vollständig gewesen. Das heißt ähm.
Belagerte Städte im Norden wie Cherry Heef, äh et cetera und halt alle Dörfer um Kiew herum, die sind dann,
quasi in Anführungsstrichen befreit worden. Also dort haben die Ukrainer dann äh.
Das Land von den Russen ähm zurückgenommen und die Russen haben sich halt zurückgezogen über Weißrussland beziehungsweise in die entsprechenden russischen Gebiete, die dort liegen.
Auch aus Tschernobyl.
Wunden geleckt. Ah ja richtig und Thernoby war ja auch dabei, genau. Mit erschreckenden Bildern.
Das äh das Erste, was sie ja äh irgendwie erobert haben, kann mich erinnern, dass wir die Meldung haben. Irgendwie okay
äh die russischen Truppen haben jetzt irgendwie Tiano Bill eingenommen, das Kraftwerk, da habe ich mir auch nur her herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ähm.
Ja, nicht nur das. Wir haben ja dann auch sind da also offensichtlich wirklich mit mit Truppen reingefahren, die einfach keine Ahnung hatten, wo sie waren und keine Ahnung hatten, was irgendwie davor dreißig, 40 Jahren passiert ist.
Sie haben da Gräben ausgehoben, also sie haben quasi sich durch den radioaktivsten Wald durchgegraben, das äh wird sicherlich für viele Soldaten auch noch mal ganz schlimme Auswirkungen haben.
Ja, aber kurz gesagt, der Norden ist jetzt erst mal befreit und frei von Krieg, natürlich nicht von frei von Kriegsfolgen.
Laufend werden irgendwelche Maskengräber ausgehoben und generell ist natürlich die Zerstörung extrem groß aber natürlich stellt das eine Verbesserung dar.
Ja und es gibt natürlich noch Großmesselange irgendwie im Prinzip in allen Landesteilen äh so auch in Kiew. Also insofern äh ja.
Ja, es ist jetzt nicht Ruhe, aber dort ist sozusagen zumindest keine Truppenbewegung, uns keine unmittelbare Angriffe durch Artillerie, Feuer et cetera. Die die versuchen halt, ja, strategische Ziele zu
erledigen, sprich Bahnlinien, Bahnhöfe, Kraftwerke, Getreidelager, all solche äh
Sachen. Aber da kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf. Wollte jetzt erstmal Situationen machen, also Norden ist quasi Ruhe. Dann über etwas überraschend möchte ich erstmal in den Südwesten gehen, weil da ist ja eigentlich gar nichts los. Mit Südwesten meine ich ähm das Gebiet um Odessa.
Beziehungsweise westlich davon, sprich.
Es gibt ja dort eine Landgrenze mit Rumänien, also so ein Streifen, wo die Ukraine bis an Rumänien heranreicht. Nördlich davon ist ähm Moldau, Moldova.
Wo ja die Russen sich auch schon mal so einen Streifen abgeknapst haben. Das ist irgendwie dieses.
Ominöse Transnistrien, wo angeblich 1500 russische Soldaten dauerhaft äh stationiert sein sollen, ob's wirklich so viele sind oder vielleicht auch mehr sind. Wer kann das schon so genau sagen?
Und na ja, das war natürlich schon auch immer so ein merkwürdiger Ort und wir werden sicherlich nicht überrascht gewesen, wäre es den Russen gelungen.
Bis zu Odessa und darüber hinaus vorzudringen in den ersten Kriegstagen, was ja verhindert werden konnte.
Hätten Sie sicherlich dort diese Verbindung.
Bis äh Transnistrien auch sofort hergestellt und was weiß ich, was sie dann noch getan hätten, ob sie dann auch gleich die Moldau auch noch mit einkassiert hätten. Das hätte mich alles nicht sonderlich überrascht.
Ist aber jetzt nicht passiert, aber trotzdem ist das natürlich ein ähm schwieriger Bereich und ähm,
Bevölkerungstechnisch, infrastrukturtechnisch ist in diesem Landstrich dort nicht viel los, aber die Russen haben natürlich ein großes Interesse generell an dem Zugang zum Schwarzen Meer beziehungsweise der Ukraine diesen zu versagen.
Es gibt westlich von Odessa keine Häfen, aber es gibt da einen ähm.
Was ist denn das so eine so ein Flussgebiet ähm wo äh eine Brücke rüberführt? Und das ist quasi die einzige Verbindung zwischen Odessa und Rumänien.
Die ist jetzt zerstört worden durch ähm
entsprechende Cruise Miss Hall Angriffe der Russen, bisschen unklar, was das so bewirken sollte, das kann alles Mögliche sein, es äh hätte sein können, dass sie damit Waffenlieferungen von Rumänien unterbinden wollen,
Getreidelieferungen nach äh Rumänien unterbinden wollen, alles denkbar.
Ähm ist auf jeden Fall so, militärisch ist es ein bisschen unklar, weil die Russen einige Probleme haben, ihre theoretische, militärische Macht.
Im Schwarzen Meer haben in Form von Schiffen äh auf die.
Auf die Ukraine abregnen zu lassen und da gab's natürlich dann überhaupt einen, der bemerkenswertesten Vorfälle vor mittlerweile drei Wochen glaube ich.
Wo ja, ist der Ukrainer offensichtlich gelungen ist.
Größe und Wichtigste, Kriegsschiff der Russen im Schwarzen Meer zu versenken.
Also in in jeder Hinsicht eine bemerkenswerte äh Leistung.
Ja, das.
Die Mosquar.
Das war definitiv ein schmerzhafter Verlust. Ähm so für Russland. Also das war so ziemlich,
wahrscheinlich das teuerste Stück Hardware, was sie denn äh so zerstören konnten überhaupt in weit und breit
Ja also sagen der Wert wird ungefähr auf 500 Millionen
geschätzt obwohl das Ding jetzt alt ist und aber allein die Waffen äh die da wahrscheinlich drauf waren äh waren irgendwie
schon mindestens 100 Millionen äh Wert, die da wahrscheinlich untergegangen sind und ähm ja, also man geht davon aus, dass mindestens also.
Monetäres ähm eine halbe Milliarde.
Mindestens war, aber vor allen Dingen halt auch nicht zu ersetzen ist. Das ist das Problem, weil sie weder die Kapazitäten haben, so etwas noch mal zu bauen
Noch können Sie eins der anderen Schiffe des gleichen Typs da jetzt ins Schwarze Meer bringen.
Genau, weil einfach der die Zufahrt zum Schwarzen Meer einfach dichtgemacht wurde von den von den Töpfen. Man muss auch vielleicht nochmal zusammenfassen, worum es sich bei diesem Schiff tatsächlich gehandelt hat. Also es ist halt auf der einen Seite
ein äh wichtiges Kriegsgerät äh extrem bewaffnet mit Luftabwehrraketen und natürlich auch mit Angriffs äh Raketen aller Art.
Ähm 500 Mann Besatzung, aber es war vor allem das Flaggschiff, das heißt, es war primär zum Schutz der äh restlichen Flotte,
äh im Einsatz. Sprich in dem Moment, wo dieses Schiff nicht mehr existiert, sind auch alle anderen äh Schiffe entsprechend gefährdet
Kurz nach der Zerstörung der Mosqua haben die Russen auch erstmal ihre anderen größeren Schiffe alle noch mal ein bisschen weiter äh weg von der ukrainischen Küste gefahren so, ja. Also die ursprüngliche Geschichte, das Ding sei irgendwie,
Es hätte einen Brand im Munitionslager gegeben und wäre dann im Sturm gesunken. Er sah, die Russen versucht,
diese Story das war natürlich totaler Bullshit. Erstens gab's keinen Sturm und zweitens selbst also selbst wenn sie es wirklich geschafft hätten die selber zu versenken, dann wäre das genauso peinlich gewesen wie abgeschossen zu werden.
Ja ähm es wurde dann auch gemunkelt, als es zumindest
das Ganze auch mit äh einem bisschen Aufklärungs äh Hilfe dann äh durch den durch den Westen erfolgt
ist, weil ähm äh ja vor allem die USA äh fliegen da halt äh
die ähm also überwachen das Schwarze Meer mit Drohnen, mit allen möglichen Radar Aufklärungs äh Flugzeugen und da wurde dann gemutmaßt ähm,
das dann sozusagen auch die die Position äh der,
Moskquar halt äh ja äh an die Ukraine ähm weitergegeben wurde, aber gut ich war jetzt nicht dabei.
Ja genau, also es gibt verschiedene Storys, die so erzählt werden von denen meines Wissens keine so richtig äh bestätigt wurde, aber wo sich eigentlich alle ziemlich einig zu sein scheinen und was auch die wenigen Fotos, die er dann von dem zerstörten Schiff gezeigt wurden.
Über irgendwelche russischen Soldaten in die Öffentlichkeit geraten sind. Äh das scheint das ja zu bestätigen, dass äh offensichtlich die Ukraine ihrem modernsten.
Diese selbst entwickelt haben und die glaube ich erst 2018 oder so in Betrieb genommen wurden.
Dass sie die zum Einsatz gebracht hatten, die sogenannten Neptun-Raketen und davon haben sie wohl mindestens zwei,
losschicken können. Das sind Raketen, die extrem tief über dem Wasser fliegen, die also nur wenige Meter über den Wellen fliegen. Das macht's natürlich für so einen äh Warnradar sehr schwierig, das von Wellen selbst zu unterscheiden.
Wobei man sagen muss, es war halt stille See, also offensichtlich war also zumindest auf den Fotos, die man gesehen hat nach dem Anschlag, wobei es nicht genau weiß, wie lange das danach war, war jetzt kein besonders bewegtes Meer.
Trotzdem ist es ja nicht wellenfrei und von daher ist das sozusagen schon mal eine Methode, wie sich diese Raketen schützen. Trotzdem könnten sie von den Radarsystemen der Mospa sehr wohl.
Entdeckt werden. Es gibt verschiedene Stories oder verschiedene Mutmaßungen darüber, was da passiert ist oder nicht passiert ist. Von,
Radar war abgelenkt durch eine Barakta-Drohne und war auf was anderes konzentriert oder das Personal war einfach nicht in der Lage, schnell genug zu reagieren, weil das ja auch alles Prozesse sind, die sehr schnell.
Funktionieren müssen und äh in den komplizierten Hierarchiestrukturen, die Russen haben, auch äh auf so einem Schiff.
Konnten sie dann einfach nicht entsprechend schnell innerhalb von einer Minute die Entscheidung fällen, was sie dann dagegen tun sollen bis hin zu Einschätzung.
Dass diese Neptun-Raketen, grade wenn sie im Tandem fliegen, sogar eine spezielle.
Abwehrtechnik am Start haben, dass in dem Moment, wo sie merken, dass sie vom Radar erfasst werden.
Untereinander kommunizieren und dann beide gleichzeitig quasi so ein gefälschtes Rasar Radarsignal zurückschicken.
Und damit äh dem scannenden Radar vormachen. Es würde sich um ein sehr viel größeres Objekt handeln und wenn dann ein äh Flugabwehr versucht darauf zu schießen, sie dann im besten Fall genau zwischen diesen beiden Raketen durchschießt.
Alles nicht bestätigt. Am Ende ist aber das Schiff getroffen worden. Es gab relativ klar sichtbar auf diesen Fotos dicke, fette Einschusslöcher.
Im Hauptschiff und.
Das war's dann. Also Munitionsdepot ist direkt getroffen worden, ist explodiert. Da sind mindestens 50 Soldaten, bin nicht sogar mehr bei gestorben und weg ist er. Die äh Moskau. So muss man auch sagen, dass,
Russian Warship, ja, was ja schon am Anfang auf der Schlangeninsel irgendwie versucht hat, einen Dicken zu machen und dann von den ukrainischen Soldaten mit nur go fuck yourself davongeschickt wurde. UKW berichtete, das ist genau dieses gewesen,
Und ja das äh hat sich jetzt halt gefuckt.
Genau und das passierte dann auch noch am nächsten Tag äh als äh diese Briefmarke rausgegeben äh wurde.
Wo auf der die Moskau dann auch noch äh drauf war und da gab's dann natürlich auch die
tollen äh äh Mehme so mit, äh wo Leute dann an der Briefmarke äh halt ein bisschen äh dann nochmal äh ja das Schiff raus retuschiert hatten, zum Beispiel aus der Briefmarke oder.
Das halt äh irgendwie in beim Untergehen zeigt. Ja vielleicht noch ja zu diesem äh zu diesem Neptun,
Schiffs
Raketen vielleicht noch, was ich halt auch aus alten Werbebroschüren, die noch von vor dem Krieg äh äh stammten über diese Rakete äh gehört habe, war auch, dass sie richtig sagt, dass es auch außerdem auch noch eine äh,
Radar absorbierende Beschäftigung hat, also auch einen etwas niedrigeren Radarquerschnitt als jetzt die anderen vergleichbaren ähm,
Schiffsabwehrraketen älteren Baujahrs.
Wie gesagt, das Flugprofil ist ein etwas anderes, also die anderen äh Flugreiten, sowohl die amerikanischen als auch äh glaube die KH dreißig oder so. Ähm äh die
von den von den Russen, die äh gehen halt im Endanflug ähm
gehen die halt eher hoch, um dann äh eher von oben anzugreifen, während du schon richtig sagtest, die Neptun das dann eher anders macht und dann
niedrig über der Wasseroberfläche
Ich habe mir dann außerdem äh nochmal angeschaut, es gibt halt so eine Szene von äh Kriegs äh Simulator Leuten.
Gibt da verschiedene auch auch Simulatoren, die die ganzen Waffensysteme recht genau modellieren und die haben dann einfach mal ausprobiert so im Simulator, äh wie äh
dass denn äh da abläuft und da kann man äh auch ganz gut sehen, wie gering dann eigentlich die Vorwarn äh Zeit,
ist so. Also,
Vermutlich wenn es überhaupt auf ihrem Radar aufgetaucht sind, hatten sie ungefähr in der Größenordnung von zehn Sekunden Zeit von dem Moment, wo sie's,
im besten Fall sehen konnten, wo jemand den richtigen Knopf hätte drücken müssen, weil
Ähm die halt, weil die Automatiken sind halt unzuverlässig, deswegen also äh außer vielleicht in zu bestimmten Zeiten fährt man das halt nicht automatisch, sondern es muss halt dann schon jemand doch noch einen Knopf drücken.
Um die Raketen abzuschließen und wie gesagt, dafür waren ungefähr zehn Sekunden ähäh Zeit, so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Nicht viel.
Zumal und das kommt ja noch dazu, das war auch in vielen Beschreibungen ähm des möglichen Hergangs auch noch so ein Thema. Also abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich allein durch Korruption,
durchaus sein kann, dass einfach viele der Systeme einfach gar nicht mehr so richtig funktioniert haben, äh ist es halt auch einfach so.
Diese ganze Schwarzmeerflotte hatte nicht viel zu tun. Die haben so ein paar gestartet, aber im Wesentlichen waren sie einfach damit beschäftigt, so von A nach B zu fahren und waren ja nicht die ganze Zeit im Kriegs.
Modus. Die sind ja nicht angegriffen worden. Es gibt keine ukrainische Navy, mit der sie sich groß hätten beschäftigen können, sondern sie haben eigentlich nur darauf gewartet, dass sich vielleicht für sie noch mal eine Gelegenheit gibt und wenn du da halt sitzt und dann irgendwie so einen Radar.
Überwachst und da wird dann irgendwas angezeigt. Ja und du bist einfach nicht in diesen, gleich kann's passieren, gleich kann's passieren Modus, dann trittst gerade noch einen Kaffee und.
Dann geht das schnell.
Ja und ja wie du schon richtig sagst, also diese diese ganzen äh Radarsysteme äh brauchen natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Wartung und Einstellung und Tuning und äh das ist halt alles
auch nicht ganz so einfach und wenn vorher dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen bewegte See war, damit ähm man
ja nicht die ganzen Reflektionen hat wird dann auch gerne was weiß ich dann ähm zu sagen
ausgeblendet, was unter zehn Meter Höhe passiert oder 20 Meter Höhe äh so, weil du sonst sonst nichts siehst und vielleicht hatten die da auch einfach nochmal äh sagen so ein Cut-off,
aktiv, äh sodass die das möglicherweise überhaupt gar nicht erfasst haben, beziehungsweise ihn das halt komplett
durch die Lappen gegangen ist. Wenn die andere Sache ist, dass aber eigentlich ähm auch
ein Shift dieser Größe hätte in der Lage sein müssen bei vernünftiger mhm,
Ja dann äh Brandbekämpfung
Wahrscheinlich hätte gerettet werden müssen, nur dann gab's halt andere Aufnahmen.
Auch äh von russischen Kriegsschiffen wie die dort.
Rumlaufen die Seeleute und in vielen Bereichen, was weiß ich, im Maschinenraum äh oder so äh saßen die dann halt alle mit nacktem Oberkörper.
Rum, was natürlich äh ja auch ein bisschen blöd ist, wenn du irgendwie überhaupt dein dein dein Gier oder deine
Klamotten äh äh gar nicht in der Nähe hast zur Brandbekämpfung und dann war's eben auch so, dass bei diesen Aufnahmen
nicht jeder an seiner Gefechtsstation
saß, sondern im Prinzip war das so, äh da waren zwei Leute, die waren am Arbeiten und dann hingen halt noch fünf Leute drum rum und guckten denen zu und alle waren so am Quatschen, also mit anderen Worten äh das sah jetzt auch nicht.
So aus, wie man sich das
äh ja vorstellt oder von von den ganzen äh äh Kriegsfilmen oder von manchen Aufnahmen so von einer amerikanischen Brücke oder so kennt, dass alle da auf auf ihre Bildschirme starren, sondern dass das sah da alles eher so ein bisschen,
Ja, letzte fairmäßig.
Es werden jetzt keine Aufnahmen direkt aus dem Kriegsgebiet, aus der Kriegssituation, sondern generelle Aufnahmen, die mal auf der Mosqua gemacht wurden.
Genau, dass die waren aber aus einer anderen äh äh Situation, also als sie im Einsatz vor Syrien äh waren. Also es war schon äh eine Situation nicht im äh also wo sie sich schon auch wohl im
Kampfeinsatz gerade befanden. Also es war jetzt nicht auch auch nicht nur so ein so ein Rumfahren, sondern ja.
Da war was wahres los, aber ja ähm das hat sicherlich auch irgendwie dazu beigetragen, äh dass sie das Schiff dann.
Zum einen, dass sie die Raketen nicht gesehen haben oder nicht abwehren konnten, aber dann auch das Schiff anschließend nicht retten konnten, weil äh ja ähm,
glaube.
Kaputt war.
Ja, also nichts Genaues weiß man nicht, aber Tatsache ist, äh das war sagen wir mal eine der größten.
Blamagen für das russische Militär in diesem gesamten Krieg, die ja an Blamagen gar nicht so arm ist.
Ja. Also und ich
die Moskra sollte auch ein modernes Brandbekämpfungssystem kriegen. Das wurde dann aber auch erstmal eingespart. Also ähm ja,
Gut.
Super Entscheidung. Gut äh schließen wir mal ähm vielleicht den Punkt da auch äh ab.
Ansonsten.
Man schauen, Transnistrien ist jetzt nochmal so ein merkwürdiger Ort. Ähm also es gab jetzt grad Meldungen, dass.
Familien russischer Soldaten abgezogen werden. Es gab naja, so in Anführungsstrichen so ein paar.
Unruhen, also das sah wirklich sehr aus. Diese ich weiß nicht, ob du's gesehen hast, diese Videos, wo so drei.
Typen auf einmal mitm Auto irgendwo vorfuhren und dann mit.
Ja. Mhm.
Äh Anti-Tenk-Raketen irgendwie auf so ein Gebäude geschossen haben, auf so einen Eingang und dann gleich wieder abgehauen sind, also das wirkte alles andere als ein koordinierter.
Ähm Vorgang und das dann halt auch gleich,
diese ganze Situation aus zwei Kameraperspektiven relativ perfekt eingefangen wurde.
Wirkte auch schon so etwas äh strange. Also man bekam so den Eindruck,
Okay, da soll jetzt irgendwas ähm herbeigedreht werden und dann gab's halt auch wieder ähnlich wie das den Russen dann zu Beginn schon mal passiert ist. Auch so eine Vorabmeldung.
Transnistrischen Zeitung, die dann irgendwie von Angriffen auf Transnistrien berichtet und so weiter, die aber,
noch vordatiert waren. Ähm also es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob da jemand versucht noch irgendwie weitere.
Weiß nicht, kriegseintritt braucht man jetzt keine Ausreden mehr für, aber.
Ja, weitere Anlässe zu schaffen, um in irgendeiner Form dort die Gesellschaft ähm mitzunehmen. Äh Tatsache.
Ist das jetzt schon relativ viele nach Moldawien auch geflohen sind aus Transnistrien, weil sie halt irgendwie Angst haben äh von der Ukraine
angegriffen zu werden, entweder weil sie jetzt der Propaganda glauben oder weil sie einfach denken, wenn die Russen von dort angreifen, dass das nix Gutes für sie bedeutet
So ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass Transistreden selbst ein großes Bedrohungspotential ist für die Ukraine, aber es kann natürlich.
Kräfte binden, ablenken von irgendwas anderem und äh dementsprechend muss man das auf jeden Fall beobachten, was da äh passiert.
Außerdem haben Sie ja dann noch, ähm wo wir noch äh wenn wir Föhn noch mit einbauen können.
Es gab ja nochmal einen jüngeren Vorfall. Also diese Schlangeninsel, ne, wo.
Dieses Russian Warship go Fuck yourself stattgefunden hat. Die haben sie jetzt auch noch mal angegriffen.
Nochmal Landeboote versenkt. Also sieht generell einfach nicht so gut aus für einen seebasierten Angriff der Russen in diesem Gebiet.
Das war.
Träumen, aber es sieht nicht danach aus, dass es stattfinden kann.
Das war auch eine ziemlich raffinierte Aktion. Also die haben dann nee, wohl erstmal die Schlangeninsel.
Angegriffen mit irgendwie Artillerie oder Raketen, die Ukraine äh und daraufhin ähm.
Haben dann die Russen 2 Patrouillenboote,
geschickt. Das sind so Boote, wo, glaube ich, zwischen, ich weiß nicht, 20, 30 Leute ungefähr passen dadrauf, auf so einem Patrouillenboot. Also sie bisschen aus wie eine größere Jacht ungefähr.
Und äh ja, als sie dann kam, um irgendwie nachzugucken oder Verletzte abzuholen oder wie auch immer, ähm haben die diese beiden Patrouillenboote äh dann äh von der Drohne aus.
Beide zerstört mit äh Raketen, ähm wo halt, ja, auch noch mal, je nachdem
sind unklar, wie viele Leute da jetzt drauf fahren, aber sicherlich auch alleine diese beiden Landeboote könnten auch noch mal bis zu 40 Soldaten getötet worden sein, aber ich habe mich dann natürlich auch gefragt, was ist jetzt mit den Leuten auf der Schlangeninsel
ja die äh Frauen, die sich traut sich da jetzt
überhaupt die russische Marine hin oder oder müssen die ja jetzt hungern. So sind die jetzt quasi abgeschnitten, aber ja, wird man sehen.
Auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich krasse Nummer auch.
Ja ähm dann gehen wir doch mal ein bisschen weiter äh östlich.
Das ist quasi das Gebiet nördlich der Krim, wo die Russen ja früh eingefallen sind und sich auch äh ganz ordentlich eingegraben haben, aber eben auch nicht so richtig äh voran äh kommen.
Ja dort dieses ähm sehr flussreiche äh Gebiet und.
Obwohl sie bei Jazzson halt über den äh ähm Fluss äh rübergekommen sind und die Stadt ja schon lange eingenommen haben und auch immer noch halten können. Ähm sind sie halt im Norden,
nicht vorangekommen, also im Norden dieses Gebiets nicht vorangekommen. Denn dann hätten sie die Stadt Nikolaif äh,
nehmen müssen, um dort in irgendeiner Form,
den äh das andere Flussgebiet zu überschreiten, Wasser von Norden nach Süden geht äh das ist dieser südliche Bug,
Ja und ähm da waren sie ja relativ früh vorgestoßen bis nach äh also,
relativ ähm weit entfernt schon von äh Jazzhorn, also ungefähr.
So 30 Kilometer sind aber dann von den Ukrainern komplett wieder zurückgedrängt worden und jetzt spielt sich das halt alles um äh Kerstin herum äh,
ab und da gibt's viele Gefechte und viel Stellungskrieg, aber da geht halt nicht so richtig was voran und auch nicht so richtig zurück. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das Thema, was wir gleich im Osten,
noch haben werden. Aber ähm,
Hier ist noch so ein bisschen unklar, also hier ist halt wirklich so ein Stellungskrieg, so ein Abnutzungs äh Krieg, es wäre natürlich für
Ukraine sehr wertvoll, Chasson wieder zurückzubekommen, erstmal um überhaupt erstmal so eine größere Stadt wieder zurückzuerobern, die verlorengegangen ist, weil äh.
Auch keine guten Nachrichten aus äh dieser Stadt und es wäre natürlich auch äh sinnvoll zumindest, die Russen an dem,
Fluss-Hufer des Dörper schon mal eingegrenzt zu haben, um weitere Vorstöße in den ähm Westen und insbesondere nach Odessa da auch wirklich komplett.
Im Griff zu halten. Ist aber nicht so.
Dementsprechend ähm ist das hier so ein bisschen Stalemade. Dieses ganze Gebiet ist für die Russen militärisch jetzt gar nicht mal,
so super wertvoll, außer dass es natürlich diese Landbrücke ähm nach Osten zu Russland schafft, ne auch ein Aufmarschgebiet.
Die Bahnlinien dort sind teilweise sabotiert worden von Ukrainern, also da läuft glaube ich derzeit nicht wirklich viel drüber oder kann nicht viel drüber laufen, weiß ich aber auch nicht
die Russen an irgendeiner Form eine Reparaturaktion haben, starten können. Es geht da immer so ein bisschen hin und her und es macht so den Eindruck, als ob die Ukraine dort eine ganze Menge
Partisanen äh Krieg auch feiert, also dass sie da.
Kleinere Gruppen haben, die sich da undercover bewegen und hier und da immer mal wieder für bisschen Ärger sorgen, aber sie sind eben auch nicht in der Lage die Russen hier nennenswert zurückzudrücken, zumindest schon mal bis zur Krim,
schon mal ein Riesengewinn. Stattdessen verlagert sich das Ganze eben so an die Ostfront.
Ja und die ist jetzt wirklich sehr schwer zu erklären in einem äh Podcast aber das ist jetzt eigentlich das wo das Hauptgeschehen ist.
Vielleicht noch kurz ein paar Worte zum.
Westen äh beziehungsweise zu der zu der Gegend, ja Khaki äh Nikolai ähm da ist jetzt auch ein bisschen klarer geworden.
Äh Kerlshorn.
Ja
und zwar ähm war da der Plan, weil wenn man sich das äh anguckt an der Küste lang, äh sind halt lauter Flüsse oder Seen äh so. Das heißt, ähm.
Sagen wenn die wenn die Russen also wenn das Ziel war dann äh war klar, dass sie nicht irgendwie
Richtung Westen, an der an der Küste lang
äh äh können, so wie äh sie das da äh von da aus nach nach Osten äh äh gemacht haben, um Richtung Melitopol und Maria.
Vorzumarschieren, sondern da war halt der Plan so über Mikolaief
äh dann bis äh im Prinzip ganz nach oben, äh so wo irgendwie äh äh Nova Odessa äh äh
ist, also quasi über Mikolaiev, dann dieses ganze Gewässer und dann quasi aus dem aus dem Norden äh dann äh nach
äh vorzustoßen, um äh nicht an der Küste lang zu müssen.
Und das ist aber auch im Ansatz,
schiefgegangen, aber das erklärt, warum die äh da jetzt äh ja Richtung äh eigentlich hoch wollten und äh äh,
zeigt halt aber auch äh ja, dass also dass sie an Odessa einfach nicht nicht rankommen so.
Dass sie da sowas von äh hunderte Meilen weit entfernt sind äh an Odessa auch nur ranzukommen. Auf dem Landweg.
Und man kann natürlich auch davon ausgehen, dass Odessa sich mittlerweile eingegraben hat wie äh,
Gutes, also da also selbst wenn wenn sie diese Orte noch überrannt bekämen, dann würde es direkt dahinter gleich weitergehen, also das ist äh nicht absehbar, dass es hier irgendwelche Fortschritte gibt.
Gut, schauen wir mal auf den äh Osten und der Osten, na ja, das ist halt so eine große Kampfsichel.
Das ist jetzt alles ein bisschen äh schwierig zu beschreiben. Man hat halt äh im Norden.
Die zweitgrößte Stadt.
Die Universitätsstadt, die ja auch sehr früh angegriffen wurde, die aber nie eingenommen werden konnte und ich hab's ja vorhin schon kurz angedeutet, Sharkiw konnte so ein bisschen freigekämpft werden. Also es gibt jetzt nur,
wenig, was noch äh in direkter Artilleriereichweite zu liegen scheint. Trotzdem gibt's immer mal wieder noch
Angriffe, aber insgesamt kommt die Ukraine hier relativ gut vor und dringt auch ein bisschen gerade so in den
in den Osten, im Osten von Sharkif in die Gebiete vor. Das wäre,
großer Gewinn, wenn ihnen da was gelingen würde und das macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, weil das eben auch eine der Hauptversorgungslinien der Russen ist, oben aus dem Ort,
Belgorot.
Ähm in in den Dornezk. Die haben natürlich auch noch andere Versorgungslinien, gar keine Frage, aber Belgorot war schon immer wichtig und das war ja dann auch nochmal so ein anderer Vorfall.
Sie dort vor ein paar Wochen mit wie es den Anschein hatte, zwei Hubschraubern.
Eingeritten sind. Also Belgien muss man dazu sagen, ist eine relativ große Stadt, eine relativ große russische Stadt, die na ja äh,
30 Kilometer von der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt liegt. Also da kann man schon mal schnell hinfliegen,
ne, nur dass natürlich die Russen auch eine Flugabwehr haben et cetera. Trotzdem scheint es ihm gelungen zu sein, da reinzufliegen und zwei wichtige Standorte anzugreifen, nämlich äh Öl,
Benzinlager. Und weiß nicht, was ich noch erwischt habe, ich glaube noch eine ähm.
Nicht nur in Lager, sondern auch eine Raffinerie mich äh richtig erinnere, aber das war für
schon ein Schock so und überhaupt ist das etwas, was in letzter Zeit häufiger vorgekommen ist. Wahr hat man sich am Anfang,
so ein bisschen drauf eingestellt, dass alles so auf ukrainischem Boden stattfindet, ist es den ukrainern in letzter Zeit gelungen,
immer mal wieder auch Angriffe auf russischen Boden zu tragen und dann eben strategisch
auf äh bestimmte Ziele. Also in dieser Region haben sie dann Eisenbahnbrücken gesprengt. Sie haben äh sehr viele Bitten Streibstofflager.
Gesprengt. Sie haben auch Militärstandorte, Munitionsdepots angegriffen, auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen, mal mit Drohnen, mal mit Hubschraubern, mal mit äh Miss Hals
Und ähm na ja, zumindest ein wenig den Krieg auch auf russischen Boden getragen.
Ja und und es gab,
relativ weit entfernt noch irgendwie tief in in russischen Landesteilen irgendwo sind ja auch äh in Munitionsfabriken äh und anderen äh merkwürdige Feuer ausgebrochen.
Die dann niedergebrannt sind, wo man dann auch nicht weiß, ja hm ähm.
War da jetzt eigentlich äh dran Schuld, ne? Genau.
Das ist das ist wirklich in der Tat super mysteriös. Also es gab äh so was zum Beispiel in Kurs. Kurs ist mal locker hundertvierzig, hundert1fuffzig Kilometer von der ukrainischen,
entfernt, je nachdem von wo man aus äh misst, ach nee, warte mal, ich muss mal hier vielleicht den kürzesten Abstand nehmen, dann sind's nur noch.
Na ja, sagen wir mal hundert Kilometer. Also das ist durchaus so ein Einzugsgebiet, wo was passiert, aber es ist auch nicht immer klar, ob das jetzt ursichtlich an der ukrainischen Armee liegt oder ob das nicht in irgendeiner Form tatsächlich ähm.
Russische Sabotage ist, also dass hier Leute aus den eigenen Reihen in irgendeiner Form die Gelegenheit nutzen, so wie wir das in Weißrussland auch gesehen haben.
Unklar. Gibt's auch nicht nur in der Region, gibt's überall in Russland, also teilweise auch äh tief im ja ins russische Gebiet hinein.
Unklar, was da passiert.
Ja, also im Nord im Nordosten von Moskau zum Beispiel, Bogozkoile, äh da ist irgendwie ein riesiges äh ja Warenlager, Warehouse äh,
auf drei Hektar äh abgebrannt ähm,
ja äh dann sogar ja in Permen gab's auch was äh in der Nähe vom Ural irgendwie tausendfünfhundert Kilometer östlich von Moskau.
Äh die äh da ist wohl die Fabrik, die halt grad und und äh Raketen produziert
äh äh scheint in Flammen aufgegangen zu sein und ja dann äh weitere irgendwie dann in Mittichi irgendwie dreißig Minuten vom Kreml entfernt, ist am 1. Mai
auch noch 'nen Tanklager abgebrannt
und äh ja irgendwie einen aus den 120 Megawatt Kohlekraftwerk in in äh in äh.
Also irgendwie ja, scheint es gerade äh in Russland bemerkenswert äh viele Feuer und ähm.
Anderen Katastrophen äh zu geben. Ach ja und und Brücken, wo also teilweise gab's wohl auch noch Anschläge auf das Eisenbahnnetz, wo die Eisenbahnbrücken gesprengt wurden.
Ja
Vielleicht noch äh sagen noch eine Sache generell äh zur militärischen Situation da.
Äh im im Osten. Ähm man bekommt jetzt teilweise äh aus der Gegend Information, welche Truppen,
eigentlich dort auf beiden Seiten tatsächlich kämpfen, also welche Einheiten dort äh sind. Da scheint es jetzt mehr äh Informationen äh zu
geben, jetzt Fairwo kämpft und ähm zur sagen wir mal,
Situationen, was jetzt die Truppenzahlen angeht. Kann man sagen, dass die Ukraine wahrscheinlich etwas
mehr Truppen hat insgesamt als die Russen, aber äh die Ukraine muss natürlich trotzdem das ganze Land abdecken. Die kann natürlich nicht äh jetzt äh das ganze Land entblößen. Deswegen.
Ist es an den Fronten so und speziell an dieser Front im Osten, dass äh doch die Russen
äh eine numerische Überlegenheit haben, teilweise von ja zwei zu eins äh bis drei zu eins.
Aber äh das scheint nicht auszureichen, äh um äh äh,
wirklich nennenswerte Erfolge äh zu erzielen, aber für die Ukraine ist es definitiv hart. Die kämpfen äh da weiter in in Unterzahl, sage ich mal, also können deswegen natürlich
auch nicht wirklich so richtig in die Offensive gehen.
Aber äh dafür, dass sie in Unterzahl äh sind ähm machen sie es den Großen da grade im im äh Osten auch ziemlich schwer.
Ja, also da ist da da waren die Fortschritte irgendwie immer pro Tag in,
ja vielleicht ein paar Kilometer oder so äh sind die da,
vorangekommen und dann am nächsten Tag wieder ein paar Kilometer zurückgeworfen worden. Also das ja.
Ähm so so sieht das da gerade aus und teilweise hm gab's auch Bilder noch.
Von der Front von einem Nachtkampf habe ich einen einen Film gesehen und,
äh da war wirklich die Hölle los. Das sah so ein bisschen aus wie im Terminator
wenn dort die ganzen Maschinen und überall Leuchtspurmunition und überall Explosion und äh Trümmer und da war wirklich die Hölle los. Da kommt man sich einfach nur vorstellen
du dich da jetzt drin befindest in
In dieser Hölle, dass du einfach nicht wirklich raus willst aus deinem Graben oder wo du wo du auch gerade drinsitzt äh äh so äh das ist einfach äh ja
die die Hölle teilweise oder war, war die Hölle ähm mittlerweile scheint
auch dort so langsam sich beide Seiten müssen ein bisschen sparen an an Munition, wobei ausgegangen ist, die jetzt auch noch niemandem, aber ähm teilweise gab
gab's da Intensitäten an Kampf, ähm die
ja wahrscheinlich fast so mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg vergleichbar waren, was so die Menge an Explosionen und Geschossen in der Luft angeht.
Ansonsten hat man das Gefühl, von den von den Bildern, die man sieht, dass äh dort.
Beide Seiten ähm versuchen,
zu gucken, wo denn vielleicht irgendwo Schwächen sind. Das heißt, man sieht dann so kleinere Gruppen von Panzern
äh anderen
Panzerkampfwagen und so äh rumfahren und äh dann eben äh gucken, ob sie auf irgendwo auf Gegenwehr stoßen und das tun sie dann halt
erstaunlich oft
was wir halt nicht sehen sind sozusagen diese sind so große Panzerschlachten wo jetzt dann 100 oder 200 Panzer irgendwo auf einmal übers übers Feld fahren. Das dafür scheinen
beide Seiten äh weder das Material zu haben noch äh ja äh trauen Sie sich auch auch das zu tun, weil Sie wahrscheinlich dann sonst äh
in in Nullzeit gigantische Verluste hätten und zwischenzeitlich war's auch so.
Dass dann die Meldungen waren, dass die Russen teilweise an manchen Tagen zwischen dreißig, 40, 50 Panzer verloren haben und das ist natürlich gewaltig.
Und die Zahlen sind jetzt also die Russen haben jetzt weit über 1000 Kampfpanzer alleine verloren.
Bevor wir jetzt zu sehr da in dieses Aufzählen der äh Kräfteverhältnisse uns da äh verlieren, ich wollte ja erstmal so ein bisschen.
Erläutern wie man sich jetzt diese Front eigentlich vorstellen,
muss. So und was da jetzt worum jetzt eigentlich gerade gekämpft wird. Also das ist natürlich überall Kämpfe äh gibt es klar. Aber die Frage ist ja, was was passiert da strategisch und mit dem Abzug aus dem Norden
und der Wiederverstärkung dieser Ostfront, der Russen
wurde ja klar, dass ich eben auch die Strategie ändert. Es hat sich ja auch offiziell so ein bisschen geändert. Erst hieß es ja irgendwie die ganze Ukraine einsacken. Jetzt reden sie von irgendwie Donnets äh und du Hans irgendwie anschließen et cetera.
Den Donbass quasi äh in Russland reinholen. Da fehlen ihnen ja noch diese Gebiete und hm.
Das spielt sich jetzt halt im Wesentlichen ab, also war es vorher noch ein Kampf um die gesamte Ukraine, ist es jetzt halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein Kampf um den Osten.
Das Besondere daran ist ja,
Das ist ja alles als Kampfgebiet nicht neu. Während das in Kiew alles ein schnelles Überrollen und schnelles Antworten war und ganz anderer Situation stattfand und alles sehr frisch war, ist das ja hier jetzt seit einem Jahrzehnt irgendwie gefühlt ein,
Konflikt hat. Das heißt, die Parteien haben sich da schon sehr eingegraben. Die Russen haben halt jetzt sehr viel da reingeworfen und versuchen eben jetzt,
der Ukraine, also den östlichen äh Teil von.
In irgendeiner Form,
sich einzuverleiben, weil dort sind quasi die stärksten und erfahrensten Truppen der Ukraine schon immer stationiert, weil sie halt einfach da die ganze Zeit im Krieg sind. Äh,
Zentrum des Ganzen scheint die Stadt Gremma Torsk zu sein und die Russen greifen quasi diesen Bereich. Ähm von,
nicht allen Seiten an, aber von Norden und von Süden und von Osten und versuchen halt in irgendeiner Form dort äh einen.
Eine Verbindung äh zu schaffen.
Versuchen einen Kessel zu schaffen, versuchen.
Versuchen das irgendwie einzukesseln und ähm kommen da aber auch nur sehr begrenzt bei voran,
Weil eben die Situation so ist wie sie ist. Also die Ukraine lässt sich da nicht so ohne weiteres äh verdrängen. Das ist totaler Abnutzungskrieg und es ist,
auch letzten Endes ein riesiges ähm Gebiet, was dort.
Eingenommen äh werden soll, ne. Also wir reden hier über irgendwie dreizehntausend Quadratkilometer äh dieses ganze Dart äh umfasst, das ist äh weiß ich jetzt nicht genau wie viel das in Saarland ist, aber ist auf jeden Fall mindestens.
Ähm genau und ähm ich will jetzt nicht tausend Dörfer aufzählen, die jetzt hier gerade eingenommen werden. Man kann sich da sehr im Detail verlieren, aber grundsätzlich sieht es so aus.
Die Rosen kommen voran, aber sie kommen sehr langsam voran.
Und sie kommen nur unter größten Verlusten voran. Das ist schon angedeutet, es gibt die Schätzung von vierzig, 50 Panzer Verluste pro Tag. Vielleicht jetzt nicht.
An jedem Tag, aber es gab Tage, wo das so war.
Und das alles nicht ganz unerheblich, ja, weil auch die Vorräte der Russen mögen groß sein, aber die sind auch nicht unendlich. Warum wir aber jetzt diese Kriegssituation, die du.
Angesprochen, als diese Panzer auf freiem Feld et cetera, vor allem nicht haben, ist, dass das Ganze hier an der Stelle vor allem ein Atelierkrieg ist. Das ist auch das, worauf die Russen
spezialisiert sind. Das ist quasi ihre billigste Munition und sie haben halt einfach extrem viel Artillerie hinter den Stellungen stehen und.
Versuchen einfach, die Ukraine die ganze Zeit aus den Feldern, aus ihren Stellungen rauszubomben. Klappt allerdings nicht besonders gut, weil.
Die sich dort eben schon seit langer, langer Zeit und mit großem Wissen darum, wie die Russen vorgehen, tief eingegraben haben. Also die dürften da wahrscheinlich.
Ahnung, welchen Abständen,
Stellungen haben, wo einfach tiefe Gräben gezogen sind, wo die, was weiß ich, vielleicht zwei, drei Meter unter der Erde rumlaufen und einfach nur bei so einem totalen Volltreffer einer Adrelle äh Atelier ähm.
In irgendeiner Form in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden. Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass die mal soeben da einfach weggeschossen werden können.
Jetzt ähm geht das immer so weiter und ähm die große Frage ist natürlich.
Was kann da äh jetzt eigentlich gegen getan werden, dass die Russen dort Fortschritte erzielen und in irgendeiner Form dort diese Landnahme abschließen und.
Debatte äh kennen wir. Es geht jetzt halt um schwere Waffen. Ja, es geht dadrum, die ukrainische Armee in die Lage zu versetzen.
Hier etwas entgegenhalten zu können und der Ruf nach Panzer an, der Ruf nach äh großen Haubitzen Artilleriesystemen,
eigentlich nach allem, was sozusagen die Kriegsindustrie bereitstellen kann. Der war ja schon immer sehr, sehr laut und sehr direkt in der Ukraine. Hier wird jetzt allerdings auch klar warum.
Denn man kann natürlich in diesem Stellungskrieg.
Zersetzend durch Gegenangriffe et cetera, diesen Vormarsch in irgendeiner Form sehr teuer und langsam gestalten und,
durchaus absehbar, dass so etwas dann auch äh irgendwann mal einen Feind, der halbwegs rational denkt, äh in die Situation bringt,
zu sagen so oh nö.
Hier verlieren wir aber echt eine Menge Material. Hier verlieren wir aber echt eine Menge Leute. Das kostet uns ja echt viel Geld. Das lohnt alles nicht. Aber wir haben's halt mit nicht dieser Form der Rationalität zu tun, sondern wir haben halt hier irgendwie mit einem ideologisch äh.
Aufgeladenen Kriegsgegner zu tun, der einfach mit seinen faschistischen äh Strukturen mittlerweile einfach jedes Maß verloren hat. Es gibt.
Dass dieser Krieg Russland Material.
Und Personal kostet in der Größenordnung von einer halben Milliarde US-Dollar. Pro Tag.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht nix ja also das kriegt man mal nicht so äh eben gestemmt und der.
Dazu kommt halt sozusagen noch der gesamte sonstige wirtschaftliche Schaden, der eben dadurch ausgelöst wird, dass eben die Wirtschaft geschwächt wird durch die Sanktionen, dass die Wirtschaft geschwächt wird durch.
Überhaupt die gesamte Situation, da läuft's ja einfach nicht sehr gut und ähm
trotzdem macht das jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, als ob sich die Russen da von von solchen Details aufhalten lassen. Ja, dann ist das halt teuer. Dann kostet das halt viele Menschen, dem uns auch egal. Wir wollen hier irgendwie dieses Territorium für uns haben und äh
Verluste auf beiden Seiten, spielen für uns äh keine Rolle. Es gibt ja alle auch wirklich dramatische Berichte,
abgehörte Soldatentelefonate, wo die dann irgendwie erzählen so, ja, hier eben keinen Bock mehr. Ja, die erzählen uns so, ja.
Auf die Frage warum warum geht ihr da nicht mit mit der Luftwaffe rein irgendwie? Warum müssten wir uns hier irgendwie aufm Feld umbringen lassen? Also ja.
Ihr seid hier die Consumer Bills, ne? Also es gibt da relativ wenig Respekt vor,
den Soldaten tun und die werden halt einfach in ihrer Verderben geschickt. Es ist halt ohnehin Gras zu sehen, wer dort zum Einsatz kommt, also wenn man sich anschaut, es gab so ein paar Stichproben.
Geguckt wurde, okay, hier mal so 2tausend ährussische Soldaten, wo kamen die denn eigentlich her? Und wie.
Welchem Verhältnis steht diese Region zur Gesamtbevölkerung in Russland? Und dann sieht man das halt einfach der größte Anteil der gestorbenen Soldaten aus Gebieten kommt.
Die eben auch zu den wirtschaftlich schwächsten, ärmsten Regionen Russlands gehören. Ne.
Da äh an der Grenze zu Georgien.
Ist so einer dieser Gebiete oder Boezien irgendwo tief im asiatischen Mittelland, Russlands.
Wo die Leute einfach auch.
Wenig andere Optionen haben und sich dann halt einfach äh von der Armee engagieren lassen, da irgendwas unterschreiben und jetzt hier verheizt werden. Was natürlich wirklich absurd ist zu sehen, dass also vor allem.
Aus so nicht russischen Ethnien rekrutiert wird zum großen Teil und zu einem überbordenden Teil.
Ähm in so einem Krieg, der halt eigentlich so einen total russisch-nationalistischer ethnischer Krieg ist.
Ähm das äh um's kurz zu Ende zu bringen, die.
Anteile von Soldaten, die gestorben sind, die aus Moskau oder aus Sankt Petersburg kommen, äh wo der Großteil der Russen lebt, ja, ist äh entsprechend gering.
So gut wie keine hörte man, also keine Einheiten aus dem Raum Moskau oder so sollen äh wohl unterwegs sein.
Mit der Ausnahme dieser einen Elite-Einheit, die sie ganz am Anfang äh reingeschickt haben, die er dann komplett vernichtet wurde auf dem Flughafen. Am ersten Tag äh das nur deswegen tauchen da überhaupt noch nennenswerte Zahlen auf.
Ja, was auch sehr krass ist. Ähm es gibt da unter anderem einen so einen Journalisten in der,
Ukraine, der ähm ja Kriegsgefangene interviewt und äh die dann halt äh,
zu Hause anrufen lässt vor laufender Kamera,
ähm wo ich mir einfach gedacht habe, hm bei eigentlich ist es so völkerrechtlich das zu Kriegsgefangene äh eigentlich nicht irgendwie vor der Kamera parodieren.
Darfst oder sollst, sondern aber äh gut
und dann ist natürlich dann auch die Frage, ich meine alle haben ihre Zustimmung gegeben so, dann fragt man sich natürlich, na ja, wie wie wie freiwillig ist es denn, wenn ich denn so als Kriegsgefangener.
Da bin aber der Hintergrund ist der ähm dass halt äh um.
Dann ausgetauscht zu werden, also es finden wohl laufend
auch Austausch von Kriegsgefangenen statt. Das läuft so so nebenher grade, aber dazu muss man halt auf die Liste kommen, also beide Seiten überreichen sich halt gegenseitig immer Listen. So
Äh und ähm ja und er macht das halt,
so, dass er halt dann mit der Kamera das dokumentiert und das filmt und die dann anruft und den Angehörigen teilweise sind da Angehörige bei, die irgendwie schon die Meldung bekommen haben, der ist tot, die schon das Begräbnis geplant haben.
Natürlich äh wo sich die Mütter dann natürlich entsprechend freuen.
Dass ihr Kind dann doch nicht tot ist und äh in solchen Fällen äh gibt,
sie veröffentlichen dann die die Videos, sowohl auf YouTube als auch irgendwie
auf auf Telegram und noch in anderen und raten dann den russischen Müttern sich halt dieses Video runterzuladen, um damit dann zu den russischen Behörden äh zu gehen.
Zu sagen, hier mein Sohn ist noch am Leben und der ist gar nicht tot. Setzt ihn doch bitte auf die Liste, dass er irgendwie ausgetauscht äh wird. So.
Äh so läuft das da ab und die Gespräche sind teilweise sind wirklich krass. Äh so mit Chris und äh dann halt die Mütter ja und sagen ja irgendwie wir sind einfache Bauern und so. Wir haben mit Politik gar nichts am Hut.
Und klar, ist natürlich auch ukrainische Propaganda, beziehungsweise die versuchen dann
also der Journalist fragt die dann auch die Eltern so irgendwie, aber warum denn überhaupt ihr Sohn jetzt hier ist, so warum denn was sie denn wollen irgendwie, Herr Ukraine und so, ja und dann,
kriegst du halt mit, ja die Leute dann ja sagen oh Politik haben wir irgendwie gar nichts am Hut und äh wissen nix und wir gucken auch kein Fernsehen und ähm ja.
Also ziemlich krasse äh Nummer, was da so.
Auf persönlicher Ebene abläuft und dann jetzt medial transportiert wird wie in keinem anderen Krieg vorher.
Muss ja auch noch mal kurz über Mario Pohl reden, also die Stadt im Osten, im Südosten, der Ukraine, die ja komplett niedergemacht wurde vor den äh Russen und wo es immer noch diesen,
einen letzten verbleibenden Widerstandsort gibt, nämlich Aase of Stahl, das Stahlwerk.
Das ja offensichtlich auch so als.
Kriegswiderstandsbastion gebaut worden ist, was wohl krass untertunnelt ist, auch äh mit vielen.
Orten in der Stadt durch diese Tunnel verbunden ist und von daher wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit so die Zentrale von den Azoftruppen war so und sonstigen ukrainischen Soldaten.
Und es ist so gut gesichert, dass die Ruster auch mit aller Kraft irgendwie von außen einfach nicht.
Gegen vorgehen können, aber natürlich jetzt die verbleibenden Soldaten und vor allem die Flüchtlinge dort äh nahezu ausgehungert haben. Das.
Sind jetzt letztlich in der letzten Woche dann doch mal ein paar hundert Flüchtlinge mit Bussen.
Sicher rausgeleitet worden.
Nachdem's ja vorher tausend Ankündigungen gab und dann Fluchtrouten beschossen wurden et cetera. Trotzdem verbleibt immer noch ein letzter Widerstandskern und hält die äh äh Russen dort beschäftigt.
Unglaubliche Situation, kann man sich irgendwie überhaupt nicht äh vorstellen. Es muss irgendwie so apokalyptisch sein wie nur irgendwas.
Ja, ja, es soll dann auch berichtet, dass teilweise natürlich Krankheiten grassieren, weil die Leute dann auch jetzt durch Hunger geschwächt sind und auf mit unter schlechten hygienischen Bedingungen, auf engem Raum und so äh also
Das ist ja äh wahrscheinlich so übel, wie es nur werden kann.
Plus das obwohl Putin ja angekündigt hat, die sollen's halt nicht stürmen äh hat der Beschuss halt nicht aufgehört. Also ähm haben.
Quasi Putin hat dann zwar ja offiziell den Befehl zum Sturm zurückgenommen äh vor der Kamera aber wahrscheinlich nur.
Aber äh ja äh ähm so richtig ja wahrscheinlich wollte wollte er dann nur war das eher mir eine PR-Aktion um äh Rang dann,
Ja nicht äh irgendwie die ganze Zeit sich vorhalten zu lassen. Äh das wird ja nix. Äh so ihr seid ja nicht in der Lage.
Ja, vielleicht mal zur.
Zum Vorgehen der der Russen, was so die Strategie betrifft. Also es ist ja personell dort einiges äh passiert. Am Anfang sind sie ja mit vielen Generälen unkoordiniert vorgegangen. Jede Front hat irgendwie für sich gekämpft, weil sie dachten
passt schon irgendwie, hat natürlich nicht gepasst. Dann haben sie äh irgendwann umgestellt und das gesamte Kommando unter diesen.
Das heißt, den Namen grad nicht äh parat, diesen General, der auch in Syrien äh eine ist ja, der.
Jetzt erst dazu gekommen ist, ähm fällt mir vielleicht gleich nochmal ein, aber eben neue Wendung, jetzt kommt eben dieser Grassimov mit ins Spiel, der ist halt eigentlich Head of stuff. Das heißt, der ist sozusagen der Chef von die ganze russische Armee.
Und der ist aber jetzt quasi,
dediziert damit beauftragt worden, doch jetzt mal bitte diese gesamte Kampagne gegen die Ukraine in irgendeiner Form zur Chefsache zu erklären,
Ja, also vorher ist er sozusagen dafür zuständig gewesen, dass die gesamte Armee als solche funktioniert, also überall, immer alles
ähm der konkrete Kampfeinsatz war jetzt nicht unbedingt sein Ding und das hat sich jetzt geändert. Dazu ist er in die Ukraine gefahren vor ein paar Tagen,
hat sich dort offenbar mit.
Führenden anderen generellen, sonstigen Offizieren äh getroffen und zwar in und das ist mitten im Kampfgeschehen. Davon haben offensichtlich die Ukrainer oder die Amerikaner und damit der Ukrainer, was weiß ich, also irgendwie,
kam's raus oder wurde bekannt oder zumindest vermutet und dieser Ort.
Ist dann gezielt mit Artillerie angegriffen worden, gibt's auch Bilder von.
Und dabei seien angeblich irgendwie die Hälfte der Offiziere vor Ort irgendwie gekillt worden und äh das war schon sehr vernichtender Schlag,
um ein Haar und dann gab's so verschiedene Berichte, erst hieß es, er ist tot, dann hieß es, er ist verletzt, dann hieß es, er ist nicht verletzt. Keiner weiß, äh irgendwas Genaues, aber definitiv er war irgendwie da und,
grade mal davon gekommen. Ja also mit ein bisschen Glück hätte die Ukraine mal eben so den Head of the Army irgendwie auch noch äh gekillt in diesem Konflikt, das wäre natürlich die totale Katastrophe gewesen. PR-mäßig.
Aber zeigt einfach mal
die Russen irgendwie auch ziemlich desgrade sind, weil es geht einfach nicht voran. Es geht gibt einfach keine großen Erfolge. Es ist einfach alles super teuer, ist alles super kompliziert und ähm selbst wenn sie jetzt Fortschritte machen und selbst wenn es eben für alle.
Alle Gebiete, die bisher überrollt wurden und noch gehalten werden, eine große Tragödie ist. Insgesamt,
scheinen die Russen zu diesem Zeitpunkt in zunehmenden Maße besiegbar, wenn man denn jetzt die entsprechend korrekte Strategie und Unterstützung für die Ukraine,
dagegen hält. Ja und das ist es, damit sind wir eigentlich auch bei diesem Punkt.
Internationalen Unterstützung durch die USA, Europa und der Welt äh gekommen und da hat sich ja einiges.
Getan. Wir haben ja die Debatte in Deutschland sehr lebendig ähm mitverfolgen dürfen. Allein schon deshalb, weil Deutschland immer vorgeworfen wurde hier,
Große Bremser zu sein und irgendwie am wenigsten zu tun, auch wenn ich mir ehrlich gesagt sicher bin, dass Ungarn noch weniger tut, aber Deutschland ist ja nun mal das Powerhaus und Deutschland ist äh
nunmal das Land mit der äh faschistischen Vergangenheit, was ich ja hier eigentlich nochmal besonders engagieren sollte, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Läuft zumindest die öffentliche Darstellung dessen, was dort passiert, nicht gut oder es läuft insgesamt nicht gut.
Ja das wollte ich dann tatsächlich mal sagen rausfinden. Ähm.
Äh anlässlich äh ja äh der beleidigten Leberwurst-Affäre äh Leberwurst geht.
Äh ja, wo ja der ukrainische äh äh Botschafter äh dann äh unseren Bundeskanzler äh als beleidigte Leberwurst bezeichnet hat, weil der jetzt nicht nach äh Kief kommen wollte
äh weil äh halt vorher der Bundespräsident ausgeladen wurde, so.
Wurde das zumindest äh kolportiert und äh ja dann habe ich mich gefragt, okay ähm weil äh natürlich viele
Stimmen auch auf total laut wurden. Es ist ja eine Frechheit. Ich meine, wir helfen ja so viel und äh das ist ja jetzt ja, das das kann ja jetzt nicht,
tun äh so, das ist ja unverschämt, so was für eine Unverschämtheit wie.
Ja, wie können ukrainischer Botschafter nur? So und dann habe ich mich gefragt, okay wie ist es denn äh.
Jetzt tatsächlich ähm und ähm ja.
Also da gibt's unter anderem äh.
Natürlich Wissenschaftler, die sich das angucken und dann auch PayPal äh dazu eröffnen und äh ja Tabellen äh machen und da gibt's dann so ein paar äh äh Kennzahlen hier jetzt aus dem Kiel working
Paper ähm stand.
Ähm sagen, was jetzt vom Anfang, also vom 24. Januar bis 23. April gelaufen ist, also die ersten zwei Monate.
Ähm also relativ aktuell die Zahlen, weil Deutschland auch aufgeholt hat. Äh.
Vorher sah's noch schlimmer aus, aber äh wenn man jetzt erstmal nach Leistungsfähigkeit geht, also Anteil nach,
äh äh Bundes äh äh nach Bruttoinlandsprodukt, äh dann ist Deutschland auf Platz
elf der Geberländer. So, aber da ist es auch erst seit Kurzem aufgestiegen, so ganz vorne sind dann äh Estland und Litauen, die dann bisher so 0,8 Prozent ähnull Komma sieben Prozent schon reingehauen
haben an an Hilfen Polen auch ganz vorne Luxemburg, Slowakei, Litauen, Kanada, UK, Schweden, dann die USA und dann kommt Deutschland.
So. Aber gut, das äh äh aber da ist Deutschland fast gleich auf mit den USA. Da könnte man sagen, na ja gut äh immerhin äh sagen.
Anteilig sind wir jetzt mit 0,05 Prozent vom BIP fast auf auf US-Niveau so.
Aber äh äh ja, in absoluten Unterstützungszusagen, äh wenn man jetzt auf die Milliarden äh guckt ist äh äh Deutschland jetzt auf Rang fünf,
mit.
Sage mal, nicht ganz zwei Milliarden äh Gesamtzusagen und ganz vorne sind aber die USA, die bisher mit 11 Milliarden dabei sind. Das heißt,
USA geben ungefähr äh ergeben mehr als alle anderen zusammen. Ja, das kann man vielleicht mal mal festhalten und da
ist aber eben auch ja an zweiter Stelle ist dann noch Polen, also Polen hat mehr gegeben als Deutschland und UK und Kanada. So diese drei Länder liegen jetzt in absoluten äh äh Werten noch vor Deutschland.
Ähm so, aber ja, gut, Platz fünf ist jetzt äh wie gesagt mit mit Aufholen äh jetzt nicht so.
Zahlen, aber nicht relativ zu der wirtschaftlichen Leistungsfähigkeit des Landes.
Und ähm.
Und dann ähm und diese Unterstützung geht halt also ist ist sagen die Gesamtsumme sowohl finanzielle als auch humanitäre Hilfe als auch militärische Unterstützung und
Wenn man,
jetzt äh sagen tatsächlich nur auf die Waffen guckt also nicht also jetzt auch ohne jetzt finanzielle Zusagen äh äh also Waffenfinanzierung.
Dann äh ist Deutschland da auf Platz 9 der
Waffenlieferanten jetzt. Ähm ganz vorne die USA.
So mit irgendwie Waffen für drei Milliarden und dann Polen mit Waffen für eineinhalb Milliarden und,
Kanada mit Waffen für ja 6fünfzig Millionen und UK will noch mit vier Millionen und so und dann ja irgendwann kommt man dann äh wenn man dann sogar Litauen und,
äh Estland und die Slowakei haben mehr Waffen geliefert, auch Italien. So und dann kommt Deutschland
irgendwo mit Waffen jetzt im Wert von äh ja 2hundert Millionen äh ungefähr Größenordnungsmäßig im Vergleich zu drei Milliarden äh von den USA.
Und ähm.
Wenn man dann aber sich anguckt, kann man jetzt sagen, na ja gut, vielleicht hat Deutschland jetzt irgendwie nicht so viele Waffen oder baut nicht so viele Waffen, aber
dann ist es so, dass Deutschland, wenn man jetzt Russland weglässt, weil klar Russland besitzt keine Waffen an die Ukraine liefern oder würde auch in den Listen nicht auftauchen.
Ist Deutschland halt der drittgrößte Waffenexporteur der Welt.
So hinter USA und Frankreich, ja und da finde ich, also dafür, dass Deutschland irgendwie sonst,
ja scheinbar äh Waffen für alle Welt übrig hat in größeren Mengen oder jedes Jahr exportiert
ist das, was jetzt an die Ukraine rausgegangen ist an Waffen, steht dann doch in einem krassen Missverhältnis äh äh dazu.
Gut, jetzt heißt's natürlich Waffenexporteur heißt, wir haben die Unternehmen, die diese Waffen bauen, ja? Das ist ja dann erstmal nicht,
im Besitz der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und wird dann verteilt Bundesrepublik Deutschland erlaubt lediglich den Verkauf dieser Waffen, der von diesen Unternehmen produziert wird. Ähm von daher finde ich jetzt den Vergleich so ein bisschen.
Schwierig.
So, wir sind der Größe Waffenexporte. Also klar, also das Potenzial Waffen zu liefern, bauen zu lassen, et cetera, das ist natürlich da in diesem Land, aber die Frage ist ja hier
Was wird von dem
was jetzt gerade da ist und sofort verfügbar ist, auch konkret bereitgestellt, teilweise eben aus eigenen ähm Kapazitäten oder eben dem, was man,
kauft. So, das müsste man ja nicht zwangsläufig im eigenen Land kaufen, wenn man Geld bereitstellt.
So, das ist ja, das ist richtig, vor allem wenn okay, wir haben halt nicht so viele Waffen auf Lager,
produzieren die halt nur auf Bedarf, wobei,
natürlich auch, wenn du so eine große Waffenproduktion hast, dann befindet sich natürlich immer irgendwas grade auch im Produktionslauf für irgendjemanden, ja?
Und da hast du dann äh natürlich schon wiederum Möglichkeiten auch
dann äh andere Kunden vielleicht zu vertrösten und ihnen zu sagen, sorry, aber ist jetzt gerade Krieg, werdet ihr vielleicht verstehen, so wenn wir irgendwie die Hälfte von eurer Lieferung äh äh so
mal äh jetzt an die Ukraine.
Liefern. Äh ja und weißt du, wo das gerade der Fall ist, tatsächlich?
Also wir werden ja eh gleich noch drüber reden, aber es gibt ja vor allem ein Modell, was derzeit so den Anschein macht. Das könnte den Ukrainern sehr weiterhelfen aus deutscher Produktion, die sogenannte Panzerhaube 2tausend. Und ähm.
Die befindet sich ja in der Produktion und ähm die nächste Lieferung war eigentlich jetzt für den Februar gedacht.
Wo aber noch nicht klar wurde ob die stattgefunden hat, da gibt's zumindest keine Bestätigung dafür und der Empfänger wäre Ungarn gewesen.
Ah.
Was ich jetzt äh natürlich am meisten den ganzen Bemühungen, diesen Krieg äh.
Zu verhindern und äh bessere Bahnen zu leiten am meisten entgegenstellt. Das ist natürlich äh sehr delikat.
Aber gut, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht,
es ist also man muss es glaube ich hier mal verschiedene Sachen trennen, ne? Was ist sozusagen Deutschland in der Lage, aus einem Bestand zu liefern, aus eigenen Besitz der Bundesrepublik Deutschland?
Nicht viel, weil vieles ist irgendwie in Reparatur kaputt, irgendwie nicht betriebsfähig et cetera beziehungsweise gibt es halt diese.
Diesen Claim der Bundeswehr, das braucht man ja selber, weil wir müssen's ja selber verteidigen, was irgendwie ein bisschen absurd äh klingt gerade in der aktuellen Situation.
Wo wobei die.
Andere ist, was kann eben die deutsche Industrie liefern, was könnte man eben finanzieren, was ließe sich dort kurzfristig herstellen und dann damit natürlich auch verbunden.
Umstellung auf westliche Waffensysteme. Heutzutage sind diese Systeme ist ja nicht einfach so, dass du sagst so ja hier ist ein Panzer und dann hast du zehn Panzer und dann dann dann funktioniert das einfach wenn der Panzer dahin geliefert wird aber du brauchst ja auch,
Munition. Du raus, Reparatur. Du brauchst Kenntnis, um dieses Systeme und vor allem du brauchst.
Eine Integration dieser Waffe mit allen anderen, mit Kommand und Kontrollstrukturen, mit äh Datenkommunikation et cetera PP. Das ist halt nicht mal eben so einfach gemacht,
runter äh vom Transporter und los geht's, ne.
Ja ja, auf der anderen Seite äh ich sage mal, sind äh ich meine, wir reden hier von Militär, ja äh und äh
da ist alles auch wieder natürlich schon nicht alles, aber vieles einfach doch stark vereinfacht, weil äh ähm du hast halt einfach auch nur begrenzte Trainings,
Zeiten äh und auf äh äh Wand und so und vor allem, weil wir ja vorher eine Wehrpflichtarmee waren. Also die meisten Waffensysteme, also ich habe
jetzt mal gehört, was jetzt so Fachleute äh sagen, äh die dann äh selber,
ausgebildet wurden oder ausgebildet haben zum Beispiel jetzt so.
Äh Panzer äh Kampfwagen, Marder war ja auch so ein so ein so ein Thema ähm so ähm und hm,
da äh gehen die halt davon aus, ja normalerweise so drei Monatslehrgänge, aber
ähm dass es halt in Friedenszeiten und wenn man äh jetzt intensiv äh Lehrgänge macht oder so, reden wir von vier bis sechs Wochen, äh wo man die Leute dann äh,
bilden kann ähm und also und das sind Ausbildungen von Leuten, also Leute ausbilden, die noch, die gar nix damit
äh am am Hut hatten. Wenn du dann aber jemanden hast, der sich schon mit vergleichbaren Waffensystemen auskennt, kann das äh teilweise noch noch schneller gehen und ähm.
Wenn man äh ja jetzt guckt, wie lange der Krieg schon läuft, mhm ja, hätte man auch schon vor,
Monaten, wo man jetzt sagen, mit der Ausbildung beginnen können und es ist natürlich teilweise sogar auch passiert. Man hat, glaube ich, teilweise sogar schon, also jetzt vor Wochen oder Monaten mit der Ausbildung begonnen. Insofern.
Ja, es ist Argument
jetzt mit Einlernen ja, das ist also es geht jetzt nicht in einer Woche oder so, aber ja in einem in der Größenordnung von
ähm ja zwischen, wie sagt man, je nach je nachdem
zwischen zwei Wochen und zwei Monaten äh äh kriegst du halt Leute, je nachdem wo die wo die anfangen
ähm in ihrer in ihrer Ausbildung eigentlich auch auf westlichen Waffensystem trainiert. Mit Ausnahme vielleicht von Piloten oder westlichen Kampfflugzeugen. Das kann dann eventuell noch.
Noch äh länger dauern, aber ansonsten ja ist das jetzt äh will sagen.
Ja, das ist jetzt also braucht's jetzt für die Bedienung der Systeme jetzt keinen Hochschulabschluss und auch keinen jahrelanger Ausbild.
Auch nicht gesagt. Ich habe ja nur gesagt, es ist insgesamt ein komplexer Vorgang, ne. Ausbildung habe ich mich gar nicht dazu geäußert. Ich habe mir das jetzt zum Beispiel bei dieser Panzerhaubitze 2000 mal genauer angeschaut
Passaubitze 200 ist aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr interessant für die Ukraine, also sagen wir mal so von dem generellen Appil her, weil es ist halt einerseits,
Wie der Name schon sagt, also eine Haubitzer, also ist eine Artillerie äh Waffe, die also
relativ kraftvolle Munition über große Distanzen verfeuern kann und äh dementsprechend halt dazu in der Lage ist, in so einem Stellungskrieg eben die gegnerische Stellung in irgendeiner Form zu bedrohen.
Dann ist es halt äh sogenannte self popelt, also das Ding fährt halt selber, da ist so ein Leopard zwei äh Untersatz drunter quasi, der äh
kann dieses äh extrem schwere Teil von 56 Tonnen
dann immerhin noch mit irgendwie 5vierzigund Stundenkilometer über einen Acker oder sechzig Stundenkilometer über eine Straße äh bugsieren. Ist also sehr schnell.
Unterwegs und ist vor allem auch sehr schnell zu bewegen, also in dem Moment, wo man so eine so eine Schusskampagne grade durchgeführt hat, dann kann man halt binnen einer Minute schon wieder on the Road sein. Und äh außerdem,
ist das Ding halt extrem gut gepanzert, also kann äh.
Entsprechenden Artillerie-Schrabnnell widerstehen oder eben kleineren Waffen problemlos was entgegensetzen, ohne gleich außer Gefecht gesetzt zu sein und,
es ist hoch präzise und vor allem schießt sehr weit,
Also es gibt sehr unterschiedliche Aussagen da drüber, wie weit das Ding so schießen kann. Nominell geht das so bei 30 Kilometer Reichweite los, aber mit der entsprechenden Munition, die da natürlich auch vorhanden sein muss, die also,
speziell ich weiß nicht genau, welche Eigenschaften die jetzt wirklich hat.
Ja, die hat noch ein Raketentriebwerk äh drin. Die hat noch eine eine Boosterrakete, um die Reichweite.
Gibt's also mehrere Varianten, das ging dann teilweise auf äh erstmal auf 40 Kilometer hoch und äh mit Spezial äh spezieller Spezialmunition.
Habe ich auch schon von 56 in einem Fall sogar von 70 Kilometern gehört, aber das erscheint mir äh keine realistische Angabe zu sein. Auf jeden Fall,
sehr weit.
Und weiter als das eben die äh russischen Artilleriesysteme machen können, sprich würde man einen Verband haben aus diesen Panzerhaubitzen könnte man aus relativ,
sicherer Distanz, also sicher im Sinne von nicht in der Reichweite von der anderen Artillerie.
Et cetera und sowas geht natürlich alles noch oder müssten die auch erstmal eine Kampagne starten, wissen wo du stehst und wenn man sich so schnell bewegen kann, dann ist man einfach auch relativ,
safe. Ähm deswegen wollen die irgendwie alle haben und deswegen äh könnte das dort ein Impact machen.
Natürlich kannst du jetzt irgendwie eine eine Truppe darauf anlernen. Klar, trotzdem brauchst du halt erstmal die Munition, wenn du die nicht hast, ist das ganze Gerät nix äh wert und vor allem,
Wie das eben generell so ist, du musst eben so eine Waffe auch äh in die ganze Aufklärung mit ein ähgliedern
Da ist es jetzt nicht mit einfachen Fußsprüchen getan, sondern da reden wir eben jetzt auch wirklich von schon teilweise hochautomatisierten Vorgängen, die also mit äh Digitalkommunikation laufen. Da brauchst du dann auch die entsprechenden Systeme, um eben
diese äh Ansprache quasi an diese Geräte auch durchzuführen, damit dann eben eine Aufklärung, die sagt, so hier Artillerieposition der Russen haben wir gefunden, das ist hier die GPS Koordinate, da müssen wir jetzt mal angreifen
So und dann liegt es halt einfach da dran, dass man dann eben innerhalb kürzester Zeit diesen fertigen Schussauftrag da einfach direkt hinsendet und das Ding einfach innerhalb von äh kürzester Zeit, ich will jetzt mal nicht auf also im Minutenbereich
Sicht dann auf dieses Ziel einschießen kann.
Auch in der Lage ist ähm fünf äh Rounds gleichzeitig abzuschicken, die alle in unterschiedlichen drei Turin fliegen mehr oder weniger zeitgleich äh landen, um also da maximalen Impact zu haben, ohne groß äh die schon vorzuwahren.
Und ähm ja, das das muss natürlich sichergestellt werden, dass das passiert. Aber es sieht jetzt so aus, als ob dieses System.
Werden wird. Es kommen jetzt erstmal fünf oder sieben Systeme aus aus Holland. Italien hat relativ viele,
Deutschland hat zwar auch einige, aber kann aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht so viele bereitstellen, aber das kommt halt jetzt und ob's dann äh eine Wirkung haben wird.
Wissen wir nicht. Die Amerikaner stellen auch sehr viele Haubitzen bereit, allerdings diese kleinen Zug äh Haubitzen, die also von so einem Transporter gezogen werden.
Auch relativ weit schießen können, ähm aber die halt nicht gepanzert sind. Also die musste halt immer irgendwo wegschleppen, aber sind natürlich dann auch nicht so schwer und haben wiederum andere Vorteile.
Die sind was weiß ich M hundertsiebenundsiebzig.
7hundertsiebzig, ja hm.
Und die sind aber auch ziemlich modern. Äh die sind für die US-Marines äh gebaut, sind halt super leicht wiegen
irgendwie nur die Hälfte von dem, was einen vergleichbare Haubitzer, also eine Haubitze vergleichbarer Leistung bringt, weil die irgendwie mit Titankomponenten auch gebaut sind und halt
auch wohl sehr schnell für so eine Haubitze sagen, in Stellung zu bringen und wieder abzubauen sind, also da redet man auch irgendwie von,
Minuten äh äh in denen man das dann einsatzbereit machen kann und
ja man braucht aber einen einen tatsächlich großes eingespieltes Team um die Dinger äh äh zu bestücken, aber was ich halt spannend finde ist ähm,
dass äh offensichtlich ähm,
bei diesen bei so Haubitzen oder schweren Kalibern, dass das Beladen von Hand oder ich sage mal halbautomatisch
du eine schnellere Schussfolge meistens hinbekommst als mit vollautomatischen Ladesystem, ja?
Also so ein eingespieltes ist äh so eine eingespielte Truppe von, weiß ich nicht, sechs, sieben Leuten, die das Ding dann gleichzeitig bedient, äh äh kommt auf eine höhere Feuerrate.
Als jedes technische System, das es automatisch macht.
Die Feuerrate hängt natürlich auch davon ab, wie ähm.
Energie reicht, dass alles dort vonstatten geht, also diese Panzerhaubitze, die kann halt auch,
Seifen feuern, aber du warst halt bestimmte Limits, weil natürlich dann durch die
dieser extremen Munition die Temperaturen äh der Rohre hochgehen und dann musst du halt einfach Abkühlungszeiten haben et cetera. Also davon hängt natürlich auch noch mal eine ganze Menge ab. Aber was sich halt letzten Endes zeigt hier ist.
Die Waffenunterstützung ist sicherlich vielfältig aber im Bereich der schwereren Systeme
liegt gerade ein Schwerpunkt auf diesen Haubitzen. Einfach um,
der russischen Artillerie etwas entgegensetzen zu können und äh es gibt jetzt schon so die Meldung, dass die amerikanischen Haubitzen äh bereits im Land und auch im Einsatz sind, das ist sicherlich bei dieser Panzerhaubitze noch nicht der Fall.
Aber kann alles noch kommen.
Ja, also das ist sicherlich dann der würde ich mal sagen, der erste signifikante äh.
Beitrag, wobei natürlich klar, jede Menge andere Unterstützung auch geleistet äh wurde, aber wie gesagt, die Dimensionen ähm ja.
Dafür, also für Deutschlands Größe und äh industriellen Output so ähm ja,
haben wir da noch nicht noch nicht wirklich äh das erreicht ähm was wir eigentlich.
Bringen müssten. So, also wir kommen aber immerhin das Positive ist, es wir kommen da hin, aber das Ärgerliche ist halt, ich meine, wir wissen doch,
alle, dass äh so am Ende ähm,
wir dann doch zahlen und liefern müssen so. Aber äh wie sagte Gorbatschow so schön, wer zu spät kommt, den bestraft das Leben, ja und äh wenn wir dann sowieso
liefern müssen. Warum können wir das nicht gleich machen? Dann sparen wir uns halt das ganze Theater. Ja?
Ja gut
wie wie das jetzt eigentlich generell aussieht in äh Deutschland. Also wie schätzt du denn das ähm ein? Also erstmal teilst du quasi dieses,
die allgemeine Wahrnehmung oder so wie das so generell diskutiert worden ist in den letzten Wochen. Deutschland währt sich dagegen zu unterstützen.
Oder unterstützt nicht richtig oder nicht mit den richtigen Methoden oder wert sich dagegen, dass bestimmte Unterstützung bereitgestellt wird, weil ich finde das ehrlich gesagt.
Ein bisschen äh ich kann das nicht glauben.
Also ich kann ich äh kann das nicht glauben, dass dass es da eine generelle also,
generell, dass da die Bereitschaft zur Unterstützung fehlt. Ich kann mir halt vorstellen, dass es unterschiedliche Auffassungen dadrüber gibt, wie diese Unterstützung auszusehen hat, aber verstehen tu ich's derzeit ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ja, also wie ich mir das also es ist es ist eine Gemengelage. So ich glaube, es ist eine Gemengelage. In der Bevölkerung zumindest äh wenn man den Umfragen
äh glauben darf und da habe ich jetzt auch keinen Zweifel äh sind ungefähr größenordnungsmäßig 60 Prozent der Deutschen,
dafür mehr Waffen an die Ukraine.
Zuliefern, als wir es im Moment tun so. Also es gibt sozusagen erstmal einen breiten Willen und
ähm so von den Parteien her. Die Grünen haben ja auch auf ihrem Parteitagsbeschluss sich dann äh relativ
klar geäußert, also die ähm sind da auch äh sagen.
Mit 80 Prozent tatsächlich äh hat der, glaube ich, Mehrheit gefunden auf dem Parteitag, also die Grüne äh Basis oder zumindest na ja äh also die Partei äh auch die grüne Partei steht hinter Hinterwaffen.
Äh Lieferungen so. Ähm ja äh die,
Opposition äh sowieso. Die FDP auch. Ähm und ähm gut.
Wenn man jetzt äh genau und bei der SPD äh so habe ich da wirklich meine Zweifel.
So. Also erstmal ähm,
ist das Ding so mein Eindruck, zumindest von der Berliner SPD äh damals war, dass in der SPD mehr Kommunisten waren als bei der Linken, ja? So.
Ähm ja das habe ich irgendwie als ich vorbereitet das gesagt habe, also ich habe das Gefühl, irgendwie bei euch gibt's mehr Kommunisten als als bei der Linken.
Ja hat er irgendwie jedes Mal laut gelacht und mir dann im Prinzip zugestimmt, weil speziell in Berlin waren halt bei der Linken.
Ja, eher so lauter Pragmatiker, während du halt bei der SPD schon ein paar knallharte Ideologen äh äh hattest und so. Ja und ähm was mich halt stutzig gemacht hat,
war und da kommen wir dann auch ähm denke ich äh dann auf das Atom äh Thema war, dass,
ja der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat es darf kein Atomkrieg geben.
Ja? So wurde er zitiert. Tue alles, um äh Eskalation zu verhindern, die zu dritten Weltkrieg führen.
So, ja und ähm aber vielleicht nochmal kurz zu der Gemengelage. Ähm äh die ich die ich da sehe. Also,
ähm da ist wie gesagt einmal die Politik, haben wir ja jetzt äh aber dann äh gibt es natürlich auch noch den Apparat.
So. Es gibt die äh Rüstungsindustrie, die,
sehr schnell reagiert haben, die ja schon Tage nach Kriegsausbruch äh irgendwie die Geparden angeboten haben und äh alles mögliche halt dann selber vorgeschlagen.
Haben, also die ersten Vorschläge kamen halt aus der aus der Rüstungsindustrie.
Ähm bei der Bundeswehr äh dagegen ist regelrecht
Panik ausgebrochen, äh dass die Bundeswehr jetzt völlig ausgeplündert wird und
die Bundeswehr jetzt äh auch eigentlich aufgefordert wurde, jetzt nun auch Truppen ähm.
So ins Baltikum zum Beispiel zu schicken und was Deutschland da losschicken konnte.
War halt äh ja auch schon so ein bisschen
peinlich, ja und das wurde dann eben auch als Indiz genommen von von manchen Leuten, die sagten, ja nee, es ist es ist wirklich eng, weil wir wir schaffen's nicht mal jetzt äh wir haben nicht mal genug Waffen, um,
jetzt äh ja die NATO um um beim Schutz der NATO-Grenzen angemessen mitzuhelfen und wenn wir uns jetzt noch welche wegnehmt äh so dann ist es ist es endgültig.
Aus, so. Das heißt, da kam.
Glaube ich massiver äh äh Widerstand aus dem Verteidigungsministerium und äh von der von der Bundeswehr äh da bloß
äh ja äh möglichst wenig aus Bundeswehrbeständen zu liefern, am besten gar nix.
Ja und dann.
Eben äh noch die so eine so eine diffuse Gemengelage von Leuten, weiß ich nicht, äh in in allen.
Möglichen Bereichen, die dann irgendwie Angst vor vor Eskalation
haben, aber vor allen Dingen dann in der in der Politik und wie gesagt und von Scholz habe ich eben genau äh das gehört und ich habe mich da ziemlich drüber äh geärgert über diesen Spruch, es darf kein Atomkrieg geben.
Warum? Du findest schon, es sollte einen geben können.
Nein, ähm äh es ist nur so, ähm wenn man jetzt überhaupt.
Atomkrieg erwähnt in dem Kontext ja äh dann,
ist mein Gefühl, dann verrichtet hier Scholz einfach Putins Werk äh so indem er äh Putins atoleren atomaren Drohungen äh Gewicht gibt, ja
so dass ich halte das also für super.
Ungeschickt ähm und befürchte, also die die Frage ist ähm,
hat Scholz denn wirklich jetzt Angst vor äh Putins atomaren Drohungen, also vor einem Atomkrieg sollten wir alle Angst äh haben so. Aber die die die
Die Frage ist halt, äh so äh muss man Putins Drohungen ernst nehmen und
Einer, der sie halt überhaupt nicht ernst nimmt, ist halt Erdogan und die Türkei, deswegen droht Putin der Türkei auch nicht mit Atomwaffen, weil er weiß,
Das das bringt nix, weil wenn du dir anguckst, wer bisher am meisten eigentlich äh wirklich direkt ähm sagen.
Militärisch
äh gegen äh Russland vorgegangen ist, dann war das die Türkei. Ich meine, die haben ja irgendwann einfach auch äh da
mal 'nen russischen Bomber abgeschossen der ihnen dann zu nahe gekommen ist der dann eben mal der der halt 500 Meter auf türkisches äh Hoheitsgebiet rüber ist und
ZOB. Ja und jetzt haben sie äh letztlich ja äh auch den den den Bosporus
versperrt und leisten damit auch vielleicht mit den größten Beitrag äh den militärischen Beitrag, um die Russen aktiv zu behindern, weil was das bedeutet, die Sperrung des Bosporus
äh heißt, dass ähm also ähm wenn Russland jetzt versucht dort,
mit einem jetzt könnten die Russen ja sagen, toll wir fahren da jetzt trotzdem rein. Nee, ist halt ganz klar, äh dass äh äh die Türkei äh Russland damit droht, so wenn ihr hier ein Schiff durchschickt durch den Bosporus werden wir das versenken.
Punkt aus, ja und es liegen ja und äh das macht halt die Türkei einfach und äh da versucht aber.
Putin äh äh gar nicht mal mit Atomwaffen zu drohen oder so, weil er weiß, dass das sowieso nicht äh äh nicht,
ernst genommen würde.
Du weißt, dass der Erdogan genauso verrückt ist wie er. Und kein rationalen Gedanken zugänglich.
Nee, tatsächlich.
Ist äh läuft das mit den atomaren äh Drohungen etwas anders. Ähm als hm man sich das gemeinhin denkt.
Ähm ja, wollen wir jetzt auf das Thema Atom? Ja, wir sind mit.
Ja gerne, wir sind jetzt Eder schon angekommen.
Atom äh Krieg so und ähm,
Erstmal äh muss man dazu bemerken, so Atomwaffen sind etwas Besonderes. Ja, das ist das ist eine noch mal eine ganz eigene Kategorie auch von Waffen weniger, ja doch,
auch sicherlich aufgrund der Wirkung, weil's hier so weil die so groß sind und ähm deswegen gibt es halt.
So etwas wie ein atomares Tabu, was sich entwickelt hat, so was aufrechterhalten würde, was letztlich im im Kalten Krieg äh entstanden ist und dieses.
Atomare Tabu äh bedeutet äh letztlich, dass äh ja ähm das Potenzial für atomare Erpressung äh auch,
sehr begrenzt,
ist und weil wenn man sich überlegt, es gab eine Zeit, da waren die USA erstmal nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg die einzigen, die Atomwaffen hatten.
Äh haben das jetzt nicht wirklich genutzt, um irgendwie jemanden zu irgendetwas zu zu zwingen. So dann.
Außer im Zweiten Weltkrieg natürlich.
Ja ja außer im zweiten Weltkrieg, aber danach, genau. Wir reden jetzt von danach, wobei im zweiten Weltkrieg äh der Einsatz über Japan, der hatte jetzt.
Der der war von langer Hand geplant und äh die musste man einfach abwerfen, weil man so viel Geld investiert hatte und äh die halt ausprobieren musste und irgendwas halt vorzeigen musste für das Geld.
Das war halt der Hauptgrund. Also ja, dass das äh äh also Invasion stand zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie
abgeworfen wurden ohnehin nicht mehr zur Debatte. Das war halt vollkommen klar, dass die ganzen Brandbombardierungen und so das das nicht
äh also jetzt mit konventionellen Waffen, dass das das Japan so kaputt war. Äh also Invasion war war vom war ohnehin vom Tisch.
Und wie gesagt, die die die Zielauswahl, das war alles auch zwei Jahre vorher erfolgt schon und und so. Aber wie gesagt, anderes Thema. Ähm
Danach aber jedenfalls entwickelte sich halt wie gesagt dieses dieses atomare äh Tabu ähm.
Und äh die USA haben ja dann auch ja Koreakrieg oder Vietnamkrieg, ja, hat den Amerikanern,
ihre atomare Bewaffnung überhaupt nichts genutzt, weil eigentlich in allen Konflikten äh seit dem zweiten äh Weltkrieg, ja und ähm
atomare Erpressung äh funktioniert einfach nicht oder auch Indien Pakistanes. Also Pakistan hat ja viel, viel später Atomwaffen
äh als als Indien und äh die haben dann halt auch Krieg geführt sagen ein Atomwaffenland und ein Nicht-Atomwaffenland, aber das hat jetzt Indien auch nicht irgendwie
also die konnten da jetzt auch keine Atomwaffen einfach einfach einsetzen. Also ich will sagen es gibt dieses atomare.
Tabu und äh weil nukleare Eskalation will halt irgendwie keiner,
und äh außerdem sind alle Atomwaffenstaaten daran interessiert, dieses atomare Tabu auch aufrechtzuerhalten und,
Ähm ähm und in insofern hm,
Na ja, weil niemand äh will halt diesen äh äh niemand will halt einen atomaren Holocaust äh riskieren.
So dass es dass es äh ähm das das Ding und man.
Immer so sicher, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ja und? Nee und? Die andere Sache ist halt atomare ProLiferation. Ähm die Atomwaffenländer wollen nicht, dass andere sich auch Atomwaffen zulegen, indem,
Moment, wo halt das nukleare Tabu fällt und äh irgendwie,
ja es ist halt auch klar dann äh sind halt eben auch die Atomwaffen,
besitzenden Länder komplett am Arsch, weil sich dann wirklich alle Atomwaffen zulegen werden. So und
deswegen das nukleare Tabu äh sagen aufrecht äh zu halten ist ist halt wichtig und deswegen äh äh und man hatte jetzt auch 50 Jahre lang haben sich halt.
Auch viele, viele kluge Leute Gedanken darüber gemacht, äh wie man das denn jetzt, wie man denn einen Atomkrieg verhindert und den Einsatz von Atomwaffen verhindert und,
Deswegen ist zum Beispiel äh klar, also es gibt äh alle Länder haben halt ihre nukleare Doktrin.
Ähm unter welchen Bedingungen sie Atomwaffen einsetzen. Und ähm.
Diese nukleare Doktrin sieht üblicherweise so aus, dass wenn du konventionell überlegen bist ähm
dann verzichtest du auf den Ersteinsatz von Atomwaffen, wenn du konventionell unterlegen äh bist, äh dann äh hast du halt eine Doktrin, die sagt ja
sobald äh ihr äh uns konventionell
zu sehr äh also die zu sehr unsere Existenz bedroht, dann werden wir Atomwaffen einsetzen und generell
ähm ja sehen äh äh die die Einsatzdoktrinen äh halt,
vor äh äh wirklich Atomwaffen.
Ähm nur unter ganz, ganz spezifischen äh äh Bedingungen einzusetzen und.
Ähm keine davon äh,
irgendwie in der Ukraine äh gegeben äh oder äh wäre auf absehbare Zeit äh irgendwo gegeben. Ähm selbst.
Ein Einmarsch in Russland äh oder so, ja, würde äh nicht die Schwelle äh erreichen nach russischer Doktrin, wo man dann äh zwingend Atomwaffen einsetzen äh äh müsste.
Oder oder würde, so dass sagt erstmal äh äh sagen, was das Doctrin Ding angeht, ähm kann man sagen, na ja gut, das ist alles alles Theorie, äh wer.
Beweis, äh wie das wie das dann äh denn denn alles in der Praxis äh äh abgeht und muss man äh dem jetzt nicht nicht doch diesen atomaren äh äh Drohungen ähm Glauben schenken, so. Aber.
Es gibt quasi zwei verschiedene Arten von atomaren Drohungen. Das eine ist, ich stelle mich in die Presse und sage, ich habe Atomwaffen und werde äh irgendwie nicht,
zögern und werde sie benutzen. Genau. Ich habe Atomwaffen und werde sie benutzen, wenn ihr mir irgendwie so ähm ja und dann.
Gibt es das, was ich eben nuclear posts ja äh äh nennt, nämlich,
letztlich wie sieht denn grade meine Alarmbereitschaft tatsächlich aus, so äh sind meine Atomwaffen
aufgetankt und äh sind irgendwie Ziele in die Zielcomputer eingegeben und sind die ja aus den Depots raus und sind meine U-Boote aus den Häfen äh äh raus äh und und weg
so. Also.
Das ist halt äh alles die Nuclear Posts, also die wie sieht tatsächlich die nuk aktuelle nukleare Bereitschaft eigentlich aus meiner Truppen.
Und das ist etwas, äh wo dann die Experten oder die andere Seite sehr genau drauf draufguckt. Ja was,
Putin oder sonst irgendwer sagt oder nicht sagt, äh das ist das richtet sich
an. Das wird gesehen, das richtet sich an das eigene Volk. Das ist halt irgendwie ja, wir sind stark, wir haben Atomwaffen und richtet sich irgendwie an Leute im Westen, die keine Ahnung haben. Ja so.
Um denen Angst zu machen. Ähm worauf halt Leute, also die Experten, halt gucken, ist äh ja ähm wo,
sind denn die Atomwaffen, wie ist denn die aktuelle atomare Bereitschaft und wenn Nas äh ja wenn und
wenn die Russen jetzt anfangen und sagen, ihre U-Boote aus den Häfen zu schicken und äh ja ihre ihre strategischen Atomwaffen aus den aus den Lagern äh äh zu holen und die Raketen aufzutanken.
So dann äh aber erst dann äh ist äh wirklich die Kacke am Dampfen äh und dann äh wird man ernst genommen, so mit äh also.
Im im Westen mit der atomaren äh äh Drohung. So, vorher nicht, aber weil eben äh man dann ernst genommen
wird mit der atomaren Drohung erhöht das natürlich extrem die Gefahr eines atomaren Schlagabtauschs dann und das will wohl also das hat sich Putin äh bisher nicht getraut. Er hat zwar
angesagt, öffentlich, er versetzt seine die Atom äh Streitkräfte in,
jetzt in Alarmbereitschaft oder in Einsatzbereitschaft, aber das war auch eine Lüge. Es ist nichts passiert,
ja? Also er hat hin äh vorher gesagt ja ich.
Ich sage zwar jetzt, dass hier eine Alarmbereitschaft versetzt werdet, aber lass mal stecken, so.
Beziehungsweise was anderer meinten äh das das, was sie da deklariert haben, diesen Zustand. Das ist eigentlich der Zustand, in dem sich diese Truppen sowieso immer befinden.
Also.
Mit anderen Worten, es ist nichts passiert, ja? Äh also nichts äh weil da ist dann Putin offenbar dann doch wieder äh so,
rational, dass er weiß, äh dass man
damit dann doch nicht spielt, ja? Also das ist dann also mit mit vorher würde man wahrscheinlich eher äh noch irgendwelche äh äh.
Raketen oder konventionellen Cruise Miss Hals äh über die Grenze in irgendwelche NATO-Länder schicken, äh bevor man.
Anfängt jetzt äh an dem Nuklearträger wirklich.
Rom zu spielen so, weil ähm ja, das ist das ist halt äh gefährlich.
Okay, gut, das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage halt, entweder jetzt äh Kaiser Scholz, das Memo nicht bekommen und weiß das alles nicht, was du da jetzt gerade erzählt hast äh oder gibt's andere Gründe? Dass du das sagt.
Tja. Also ich glaube, er hat das äh er hat das Nemo nicht gelesen. So äh oder wie das halt oft so ist, dass halt dann ich meine, man kann sich als Politiker nicht um um jede jedes Detail.
Kümmern und Deutschland hat.
So wie Atomkrieg.
Nee äh ähm und ähm.
Ja und Deutschland gut, wir haben jetzt die atomare Teilhabe äh äh und so, aber äh ja also.
Entweder wie gesagt also wenn er das Memo nicht gelesen hat, es wäre das verzeihlicher als äh wenn er das eigentlich weiß,
alles, ja, als wenn ihm das sozusagen klar ist und er jetzt äh dann aber nur abstrakte Spekulationen anstellt äh und dann ja eine Gefahr
heraufbeschwört, die vielleicht irgendwann irgendwie entstehen kann, so. Aber ja äh.
Aber wie wir jetzt auch gesehen haben, äh so, wenn man wir stehen auf der Feindesliste und ähm,
ja jetzt werden halt alle möglichen schweren Waffen geliefert und es sieht jetzt nicht so aus, als wenn äh Putin,
wirklich jetzt vorhätte, sich auch noch mit der NATO anzulegen in dieser Situation, egal ob nuklear oder äh konventionell. Ähm.
Man was halt ich eine Zeit lang nicht ausgeschlossen habe äh war äh sagen eine.
Ja eine Art nukleare Demonstration, die jetzt nicht wirklich einen einen direkten Angriff auf eine militärisches Ziel äh darstellt, sondern zu sagen
irgendwo eine zu zünden, was weiß ich, über der Ostsee zum Beispiel. Und.
Dafür gibt's aber auch einen Szenario. Das ist also diese wohl die ganzen Pläne, wie man,
auf äh den Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen äh reagiert, berücksichtigen auch
so ein Szenario, also eine sozusagen eine taktische Atomwaffen äh äh Demonstration zum Beispiel über der über der Ostsee und ähm.
Natürlich gibt es da dann als als Antwort, wenn wenn Putin so etwas versuchen würde ähm.
Äh gibt gibt es da nicht eine Standard Antwort, äh sondern da,
gibt's halt eine ganze Reihe möglicher Antworten, aus denen dann wahrscheinlich der amerikanische Präsident äh auswählen würde, wenn wenn das passiert, ähm aber.
Was ich zumindest von Fachleuten, die die Pläne.
Kennen, äh gehört habe, äh war, dass äh diese Antwort.
Auch auf eine Demonstration äh sagen so äh ausfallen wird, äh dass äh dass kein anderes Land jemals wieder versuchen wird.
So ist diese Antwort designed. Ähm um eben, wie gesagt, zur Aufrechterhaltung des nuklearen Tabus.
Also schon auch eine nukleare Antwort.
Ähm die muss nicht notwendigerweise nuklear ausfallen. Das kommt.
Äh drauf an, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß, dass äh äh beziehungsweise es gibt auch also es gibt auch nicht nukleare Antworten äh äh in diesem Spektrum, aber ähm.
Ja äh ähm wie gesagt, die von, ich sage mal, ähm.
Die die einfachsten Antworten äh reichen, äh dann von totaler wirtschaftlicher Blockade. Also.
Wirklich grenzendicht. Keiner kommt mehr rein oder raus aus dem Land, ja,
So diese diese Art äh von von äh Reaktion komplette, also komplette wirtschaftliche Isolation plus man natürlich auch sehen muss äh dass zum Beispiel auch China.
Äh oder auch Indien,
Auch not amused äh äh wären, wenn äh wie gesagt Russland dieses Nukleare Tabu brechen würde. Also das würde sagen, da das ist quasi die unterste Schwelle. Ähm.
Dann ähm ja äh ist wahrscheinlich aber mindestens ein äh äh massiver äh militärischer Schlag gegen.
Alle möglichen Militärinstallationen zu erwarten, der nicht notwendigerweise nuklear sein muss, aber,
Also am Anfang war sozusagen gab's als Strategie nuklear retaliation. Das war sozusagen okay, wenn.
Ihr irgendwie auch nur eine mit einer einzigen Bombe ankommt, dann äh feuern wir alles ab, äh was wir haben.
So ähm dann
hat man das verfeinert, na ja gut, vielleicht wär's sicherer, wenn wir uns ein breiteres Spektrum vorbehalten und dann gab's halt die sogenannte flexible Response.
Das heißt, äh dass man grundsätzlich vorhatte, sagen so zu also,
ja in gleich in in gleicher Münze ungefähr äh zu antworten. Also dann, was weiß ich, wenn dann das das würde bedeuten, wenn Russland dann irgendwie eine über.
Der äh über der Ostsee zündet oder so, dann
man vielleicht keine Ahnung ähm irgendeine würden die Amerikaner irgendwo auch überm Wasser in der Nähe von Russland äh irgendwo eine zünden, so das wäre flexibel
Response. Ähm
Aber äh was ich so rausfinden konnte jetzt über die Debatte ähm über den aktuellen Stand ähm.
Der ähm ja der der Nukleardoktrin ist, dass in den letzten Jahren auch im Zusammenhang mit der Ukraine äh äh sehr viel von,
Äh äh äh die die Sprache äh war, das heißt ähm was auch immer äh.
Man äh tut. Also man muss jetzt nicht das ganze Arsenal äh äh gleich sofort abschießen, aber was immer man
man tut als Antwort ähm äh soll die so ausfallen, dass
äh anschließend äh ja Russland in dem Fall nicht mehr in der Lage ist äh ja äh seine,
Waffen oder sein Militär weiter einzusetzen. So.
Ist ja auch jetzt in der aktuellen Debatte ist das ja eigentlich auch schon die geäußerte Hoffnung
Unabhängig mal von der Antwort auf einen möglichen Nuklearschlag, aber das ist ja auch generell jetzt so die äh Prämisse oder die Hoffnung oder das erklärte Ziel vielmehr des Westens, dass man sagt so hm na ja okay, an dem Punkt, wo wir jetzt sind äh.
Hätten wir's natürlich auch gerne, dass die Russen sich auch so final abnutzen, dass sie überhaupt gar keine Gefahr mehr darstellen, aber wir machen das halt irgendwie The Longway.
Nicht durch totale Zerstörung. Ähm hast du noch zu diesem Atomkriegsaspekt noch jetzt was zu zu sagen, weil sonst würde ich.
Debatte vielleicht nochmal weiterschieben, wie es so generell weitergehen könnte.
Wie gesagt, vielleicht doch, ja, zusammenfassend, also ja äh so Atomwaffen,
machen Angst und zu Recht, aber äh man muss halt trotzdem eben einen klaren Kopf behalten ähm so und äh.
Sagt äh laut Atomdoktrin äh zumindest,
Ist ein einen taktischer Einsatz von Atomwaffen in der Ukraine äh nicht.
Gegeben so dann und nukleare Erpressung, wie gesagt.
Hat in der Vergangenheit nicht gut funktioniert und wird
auch jetzt nicht funktionieren eben wegen wie gesagt dem nuklearen Tabu und
so wegen dem großen globalen Interesse daran, es durchzusetzen und und und aufrecht zu erhalten und so und natürlich äh sollte man aber äh im im Auge behalten so.
Dass es schon einzelne Fälle gibt, äh wo die Nutzung von Atomwaffen wahrscheinlicher machen und da muss man halt aufpassen und äh ansonsten ja äh.
Äh ja, nukleare Eskalation, eine Frage eben von Abschreckung und von äh entsprechender Signalisierung äh auch, dass man halt einfach klare.
Botschaften sendet, ja, das ist halt ganz wichtig, dass man halt äh sagen oder oder hinreichend klare äh Botschaften sendet, nicht bis ins äh Kleinste, die,
Detail, aber eben klar macht nie. Also da das ist wirklich eine eine rote,
Linie und in dem Fall äh ist jeder Einsatz von Atomwaffen ist halt eine äh wäre ein Fall, der diesen Konflikt.
Auf eine ganz, ganz neue Ebene behebt, ja, der äh sozusagen.
Das äh wäre dann das hätte dann sozusagen die Ukraine wäre dann nur noch Nebenschauplatz. Ja wenn wenn das wenn das passiert.
Und ähm ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass äh ja äh äh Putin und das russische Establishment so,
wahnsinnig sind, sondern ähm,
das sind halt ja berechnende Macht-und Geldgierige Kleptokraten und äh ja da ist halt kein Profit.
Äh zu erwarten.
Ich habe auch einiges darüber gelesen, wo.
Generell ins Zweifel gezogen wurde, dass das russische nuklear Potenzial überhaupt noch in dem Maße einsetzbar ist. Ähm.
Jetzt leider noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen, aber wer vielleicht jetzt nochmal als Ergänzung auch ganz interessant.
Okay. Mhm.
Ähm Amerikaner wenden ja relativ viel Geld auf, um ihr nuklear.
Material in Betrieb zu erhalten, irgendwas in der Größenordnung von 10 Milliarden US-Dollar pro Jahr.
Das ist schon mal eine ganz ordentliche Zahl, weil das irgendwie, glaube ich, ein Viertel von dem ganzen Militär äh Haushalt der der Russen und die wenden sicherlich nicht so viel auf. Und es ist ja auch so ein bisschen.
Angeklungen,
dass jetzt verschiedene Faktoren sind, die dazu beitragen, dass unter Umständen diese Mengen an Nuklearwaffen, die die Russen angeblich haben, so behaupten nicht da sind oder überhaupt nicht mehr benutzbar sind.
Einfach weil Geld, was tatsächlich in den Erhalt gesteckt wurde theoretisch, praktisch vielleicht dann in der Korruption hängen geblieben ist. Gut, dass es hier so ein bisschen Mutmaßerei.
Aber äh das einfach auch generell nicht getan wird, selbst wenn das erfolgen würde, so wie angeordnet, um einfach diese Mengen an Waffen äh betriebsfähig zu halten. Da,
man stellt sich das ja immer so vor, na ja Waffe baut man, legt man ins Regal, holt mal raus, wenn man's braucht. Ne?
Mag für Pistolenkugeln gelten und äh ein Stück weit auch für Artilleriegeschosse et cetera, also konventionelle Waffen.
Aber bei Atomraketen ist es ja alles ein sehr delikate Geschichte, die sehr viel mit radioaktivem Zerfall zu tun hat und der findet ja auch statt, selbst wenn's keinen Krieg gibt.
Ja, das ich meine, das Thema hatte ich mir auch mal etwas genauer angeguckt, so wie wie ist es denn um die Haltbarkeit äh so bestellt, sowohl von jetzt konventioneller
Munition äh Artilleriegranaten, diesen,
Raketen äh generell und auch bei bei Atomwaffen und ähm ja
kann man so sagen äh zum zum Beispiel so eine so eine Stinger oder so eine Javelin haben einen von zehn bis zwölf Jahren,
danach äh werden die nicht mehr garantiert vom äh vom Hersteller Artillerie Munition äh zwischen 15 und 25 Jahren, wobei.
Shavelive äh äh ja von 25 Jahren dann bedeutet, dass äh die
so zuverlässig ist wie Fabrik neu, das ist also praktisch nicht äh keine höheren äh äh Versagens äh Raten.
Ähm im Schnitt wohl habe ich gesehen, je nach Munitionssorte, aber
lagen dann wohl in der Praxis bei den Amerikanern
lange gelagerter Munition äh so bei Art Hille Rigranaten irgendwo bis zu zwei oder drei Prozent äh haben nicht ordentlich funktioniert äh so oder bye-bye bei Bomben.
Aber sagen eigentlich moderne äh Munition äh kommen kommen Versager eigentlich.
Sollten nicht nicht vorkommen. Also ihrem nahe hundert Prozent äh eigentlich, wenn die aus der aus der Fabrik kommen oder.
Gut man das das halt messen kann so. Ähm diese Katjuscha-Raketen ungefähr, die halten auch, die halten sogar interessanterweise länger. Äh also
Ja diese diese Nerven diese Raketen nehmen Mehrfachraketen mehr falsch. Früher hießen die aber ähm ja die haben so 25 bis 35 Jahre äh kann man die lagern.
Und bei Atomwaffen.
Äh ist es so, äh dass da die Trägersysteme am Wartungsintensivsten und teuersten äh äh sind, die Sprengköpfe selbst ähm haben wohl, also die, die
aktuellen russischen Sprengköpfe haben ungefähr auch einen von zehn Jahren. Ähm maximal ähm geht man geht man von aus ähm,
ältere äh Systeme hatten dann teilweise auch nur drei bis sechs Monate beziehungsweise äh die musste dann erst zusammen.
Bauen vor dem vor dem Einsatz muss dann was weiß ich frisches Polonium einfüllen oder frisches Tritium äh ein äh äh füllen in die Neuronenquelle
ähm oder für den Neutronengenerator.
Dass es so im Übrigen das, was am am am schnellsten verfällt, äh die äh entweder das das Trizium oder das Polonium für den Neuronen äh Generator, wobei äh halt
Trizium, wie gesagt, mit einer Halbwertzeit, glaube ich, von von zwölf Jahren oder so. Ähm,
ja äh das das letztlich das Kritischste ist
Dazu kommt aber auch noch natürlich die ganze Elektronik. Hm, du hast halt diese ja.
Diese explosiven Linsen wie es so schön heißt das sind halt der um,
den um das spaltbare Material äh herum angeordnete äh äh Kern an konventionellem Sprengstoff, der dann äh den äh äh Kern entsprechend komprimiert.
Und das muss halt alles ähm auch in der.
In der richtigen konstanten äh Zeit mit der richtigen Explosionsgeschwindigkeit,
brennen und auch sagen zeitgleich abbrennen und wenn da auch nur ein oder zwei Linse versagt oder zu spät zündet oder äh äh nicht nicht so richtig,
ähm mit der richtigen Geschwindigkeit abbrennt, dann
äh so äh kann das ganz leicht passieren, dass äh die der der hielt, also
die Explosivkraft der Atomwaffe äh nur äh um um Größenordnungen niedriger, also Faktor zehn, hundert, tausend, zehntausend ähm geringer ist als ähm.
Eigentlich vorgesehen und äh ja plus das wohl auch eine eine Reihe
äh natürlich der der eingesetzten Metalle und Stoffe eben auch entsprechend korrosiv.
Sind und dann hält die hängt die Haltbarkeit auch davon ab äh dass du das bei
dass du diese generell Munition halt kühl und trocken lagerst
äh und bei gleichbleibenden Temperaturen äh und da ist dann halt auch die Frage, wenn du dann halt irgendwo Lager hast, wo dann,
Ist im Winter kalt und im im im Sommer warm ist, dann altert die Munition oder die die Waffen entsprechend.
Auch und das ist wahrscheinlich auch mit einer Erklärung, warum die Russen teilweise auch eine Menge Munitionsversager wohl gerade äh haben. Plus, dass man nicht weiß, äh ob nicht vielleicht schon einfach auch die Qualitätskontrolle ab,
ab vielleicht äh mangelhaft sein könnt, aber es abzuschließen.
Ich befürchte die Russen dürften schon
noch eine Reihe von funktionierenden Atomwaffen haben, ja, also darauf äh kann man sich jetzt nicht nicht verlassen, äh dass da nix funktioniert.
Beruhigend also ja gut also um's mal die Gesamtdiskussion vielleicht zusammenzufassen du gehst davon aus dass.
Atomkrallkrieg, deshalb nicht stattfindet, weil keiner ihn will und das schließt die Russen mit ein.
Und das ähm selbst wenn es denn einen gäbe ähm Russland zwar in der Lage wäre einen auszulösen, aber weniger ihn zu beleben.
Äh dass vor allem weil sie vermutlich.
Ein doch eher schwächlichen, schwächelnden Bestand an Nuklear äh Kräften haben. Was ja nicht bedeutet, dass sie mit dem, was noch funktioniert, nicht eine ganze Menge Ärger anrichten können.
Aber es wäre sozusagen auch noch mal ein zusätzliches Risiko für für Russland, wo auch.
Eben dann unklar ist, inwieweit ja ähm die Dinger denn dann auch auch funktionieren äh wird äh ich meine es gibt
Es gibt durchaus wie gesagt Fälle
äh äh die eine nukleare Eskalation möglich oder wahrscheinlich äh äh machen, aber ähm
da müssten dann wirklich schon, ich glaube die Truppen von Moskau stehen
ja? Also selbst wenn die irgendwie in weiß ich nicht ein paar hundert Kilometer ins Land äh äh rein während NATO-Truppen glaube ich würde Russland trotzdem äh noch nicht
äh den den Nuklear äh Träger, also ähm ja gut.
Nicht, dass wir deswegen das das nicht, dass wir das austesten sollten, aber zumindest nach nach Nukleardoktrinen äh äh müsste, eben tatsächlich der Bestand Russlands äh.
Ernsthaft gefährdet
äh sein, ja? Oder äh eben gut die andere Sache ist noch die Verteidigungsbereitschaft, also nur sagen, wenn quasi man Russland atomar äh atomar entwaffnet,
werden
könnte oder ja wenn es drohte atomar entwaffnet zu werden, indem man halt sämtliche Trägersysteme und Flugzeuge oder Kommunikation zerstört, wie auch immer, dass es halt auch so ein Fall in der in der,
Doktrin so. Aber solange Russland noch seine Atomwaffen hat und seine Kontrolle äh äh darüber hat, ähm.
Ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass es sie einsetzt. So oder äh nicht zu verlieren droht, so so würde ich, so so könnte man das vielleicht formulieren, ja?
Ich habe auch verschiedene Einschätzungen gelesen. So ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass dass ich da jetzt alle so einig sind, ne. Ähm aber ein Aspekt, der auch wieder aufkam, war,
Sollte Putin tatsächlich so eine Entscheidung fällen.
Würde ihm sein Militär den Vogel zeigen und das wäre dann sozusagen auch so eine rote Linie äh innerhalb der Machtstruktur Russlands, an der unter Umständen.
Sich das System teilt und äh der Apparat sagt so, sorry ja, nee, aber das das tragen wir jetzt nicht mit.
Trotz aller Bedrohungen und und und äh Unterdrückungen.
Genau und dafür gibt's halt dann eben schon die Doktrin und äh sagen dann ja und Atomwaffen außerhalb äh sagen der der Doktrin.
Einzusetzen. Das könnte dann tatsächlich eben auch dann vom Apparat äh ja verweigert werden möglicherweise. Aber.
Ja also äh man sieht es es gäbe zumindest auch eine eine Reihe, also es gibt eine ganze Menge auch.
Hindernisse, ne, die halt einem Atomwaffeneinsatz entgegenstehen. Das ist nicht so, dass äh man das mal eben so macht.
Wie erfreulich.
Widmen wir uns doch mal äh einem anderen Aspekt, nämlich der Frage, ob Russland jetzt noch Eskalationspotential hat.
Ähm wir haben jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von den ganzen Nuklearwaffen ist es ja so, dass äh,
Nachschub zu liefern bisher, für Russland vielleicht möglich war, aber nicht unbedingt einfach war und es hier und da auch
Hinweise darauf gibt, dass sich die Gesamtsituation waffentechnisch bei Russland auch nicht unbedingt positiv entwickelt. Das gilt natürlich derzeit auch noch für die Ukraine, aber mit der,
Unterstützung des Westens und im Prinzip auch der äh,
Ansage, kann man davon ausgehen, dass sich die Waffensituation der Ukraine.
Mit Scholz und Deutschland hin und her, ja, Perspektive,
kontinuierlich verbessern wird und zwar sowohl was die Verfügbarkeit quantitativ betrifft, als auch was so die Fähigkeit der Waffen
qualitativ betrifft. Das ist eine Frage der Zeit. Das wird sich äh entwickeln, ja. Ausbildungen werden gemacht werden, die Forungen werden durchgeführt werden, Systeme werden integriert werden, also,
mittelfristig und ich denke, man muss diesen Krieg jetzt schon auch noch in Monatsdimensionen mindestens betrachten.
Mittelfristig wird sich also die Situation der Ukraine verbessern, also was die Waffenausstattung betrifft, erst nur nur gesagt.
Mittelfristig wird sich die Waffensituation bei den Russen glaube ich nicht so gut entwickeln, weil erstens, die beliefert keiner.
Zweitens, die haben wahrscheinlich schon einen Großteil ihrer.
Modernen Waffen bereits zum Einsatz gebracht und wenn man jetzt so sich Bilder anguckt von Nachschubzügen.
Ja, wo so Material äh rein äh reingereicht wird, so was gibt es aus Russland, gab's ja am Anfang auch aus äh Weißrussland immer wieder, liegt da mal was durch.
Das lässt sich ja sozusagen kaum verbergen, ne. Die stehen da irgendwie auf diesen Zügen drauf und werden einfach durchs Land gefahren.
Und mittlerweile haben sie also auch schon die Haubitzen irgendwie ausm Zweiten Weltkrieg, die sie irgendwie noch rumliegen hatten äh,
an Start gebracht. Also man merkt, dass quasi die Versorgung mit modernen Waffen,
nicht mehr so funktioniert. Ähnlich dürfte es wahrscheinlich dann bei den ähm bei der Munition aussehen.
Und vor allem natürlich auch bei den Panzern. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wann wir diese Rechnung, hatten wir in der letzten Sendung schon mal diese Rechnung aufgemacht. Ich glaube gar nicht mal, dazu kam's jetzt, glaube ich, nicht. Aber es ist halt auch einfach so, dass die.
Zahl der Panzer, die da jetzt nachweislich vernichtet wurde. Ja, also dokumentiert sind ja, glaube ich, mittlerweile fast bis zu tausend Fälle.
Tausend Panzer. Das ist schon,
ganze Menge Holz, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass sie da bestenfalls irgendwie mit 2500 Panzern wirklich vor Ort sind. Sprich ein Großteil
ihrer Kampfkraft geht verloren und sie verlieren vor allem überproportional moderne Waffen. Also der Anteil unter den dokumentierten.
Zerstörten Panzersystem oder Panzerfahrzeugen et cetera. Der Anteil der.
Moderneren Modelle war bei dem, was man sah, höher als er eben normalerweise im.
Äh in der Armee laut ihren eigenen Zahlen äh sein kann. Sprich hm das verbessert sich halt äh nicht so richtig.
Ja, sag nochmal was zu den Waffen. Ich wollte nochmal auf diese Mobilisierung zu sprechen kommen.
Ja ähm äh gut zum einen schickst du natürlich schon normalerweise äh deine,
besseren Waffen und besseren Truppen erstmal in den in den Kampf äh wenn du die mobilisierst ähm mit dem moderneren Equipment,
Und dann ist es aber auch so üblich in jeder Armee, dass die
Truppen, die jetzt in den in den Einsatz gehen, also üblicherweise hast du ja so so Zahlen von Einsatzbereitschaft 60 Prozent
oder so bei bei irgendeiner äh äh Truppe oder im Schnitt bei irgendeiner Waffengattung und jetzt willst du natürlich.
Das Ganze natürlich kein äh Verband eigentlich, der nur zu 60Prozent einsatzbereit ist, wird's jetzt nicht irgendwie frisch oder eine Zeit irgendwie mit 100 Prozent in den Kampf schicken. Also,
nimmst du halt dann, wenn wenn's um technisches Gerät geht nimmst du halt dann
auch noch die Waffen und das Gerät und die Reserven von Truppen, die jetzt nicht in den heißen Einsatz gehen, sondern äh aus den Reserven letztlich oder aus anderen
Ja äh äh von anderen äh Verbänden und Einheiten, um die, die losmüssen, dann wenigstens einsatzfähig zu machen. So, das heißt,
Wenn die aber jetzt so wie das passiert
in dem Maße auch entwaffnet werden oder einen solchen Verschleiß haben, äh dann äh wird es eben immer schwieriger auch noch äh voll einsatzbereite Truppen
ähm in den in den Kampf zu schicken, weil du die vorher schon mal geplündert hast, äh um die erste Gruppe äh zu schicken so, ja.
Also äh das ist dann auch noch mal so ein so ein so ein Mechanismus, der sehr unangenehm ist.
Und dann ähm aus aus vielen Schilderungen jetzt auch von von Kriegsgefangenen ähm.
Die dann so erzählten, wie das für die gelaufen äh ist. Ähm war dann äh äh auch
ja äh war's oft so, dass sie halt in ja praktisch Kompaniestärke von mit 100 Soldaten im Verband losgezogen sind und es am Ende nur noch zehn übrig waren.
Von den hundert. Die 90 waren jetzt nicht alle tot, die Hälfte ist abgehauen irgendwie. Hat gesagt, wir kündigen so, weil wir machen da nicht mehr mit. Ähm
oder sind einfach äh so äh weg und ja am Ende standen sie also die jährigen Gefangenschaft gerade, sie meinten die standen da nur noch irgendwie mit zehn Mann.
Rum oder auch so so Dinge.
Wie das die Hälfte der Leute keine Lust hatte äh weiter vorzumarschieren.
Einfach Befehl verweigert hat ne wir greifen nicht an
und äh dann halt äh der auf entnervte Offizier gesagt, ja gut, dann bleibt eben hier und verteidigt und dann sind die halt sind halt dreißig Leute in der Verteidigung zurückgeblieben und er musste mit zehn Mann los
äh äh in den Angriff und so. Ja, egal. Ähm du wolltest äh jetzt noch mehr zu den Waffen sagen?
Nee, ich wollte vor allem was dazu sagen, weil wie Russland sich jetzt sozusagen in dieser Situation ja perspektivisch mir kommuniziert mit.
Euch geht irgendwann das Material aus, ja? Oder euch geht vor allem auch das Personal aus,
Weil ihr habt irgendwie keine Möglichkeit nachzuproduzieren, die ähm.
Derzeit keine Fabriken, die Panzer produzieren und selbst wenn's die gäbe, äh also natürlich gibt's die Fabriken, aber die können halt grade nicht produzieren, weil sie einfach kein Material kriegen, weil es keine Elektronik
weil sie von den Sanktionen betroffen sind und dazu, selbst wenn sie das tun würden, könnten sie nicht ansatzweise so viel Panzer produzieren wie da jetzt grade täglich zerstört werden
Also das ist äh einfach unmöglich, ja. Die haben vielleicht da eine
jetzt gerade vergessen, was da so die die jährliche Produktion ist, aber das äh geht da in einer Woche in in der Ukraine, geht das irgendwie locker hops.
Und ähm.
Auch das Personalproblem besteht da. Man hat zwar derzeit noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass das irgendwie besteht. Offensichtlich sind noch genug da, um in diese ganze Kampagne voranzutreiben, aber eben auch nicht besonders schnell und perspektivisch
auch nicht unbedingt schneller,
Und was ja jetzt viel diskutiert wird, ist, wird Putin sozusagen eine Generalmobilmachung ausrufen. Wird er jetzt,
9. Mai dazu nutzen, der Ukraine offiziell den Krieg zu erklären, weil derzeit läuft das ja alles noch unter Special Military Operation und ähm
Es würde sicher rechtlich auch etwas ändern in dem Moment, wo hier ein äh fullblown äh War ausgerufen wird
weil's dann ja eben bedeuten würde, dass er eben auch die ganzen Reservisten einbeziehen kann. Und die Frage ist.
Mhm.
Würde er das tun? Ja, weil klar, damit natürlich sofort mehr Leute zur Verfügung. Nur, das heißt ja dann auch,
Das betrifft dann die Wirtschaft sofort, weil die Leute werden ja quasi aus den wirtschaftlichen Betrieben abgezogen. Gut, kann man sagen, Sanktionen ist eh grad nicht so viel zu tun.
Es wäre halt ein sehr.
Teurer Schritt auch. Also das äh bedeutet nochmal sehr viel mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen, so viele Leute, weil die müssen ja dann irgendwie,
kompensiert werden et cetera äh ne es ist auch nichts, was von heute auf morgen.
So liefe, also du kannst nicht mal eben so schnipsen und dann hast du irgendwie 1hunderttausend Truppen vor der Tür, sondern.
Ja, die werden dann aufgerufen, keine Ahnung, dann müssten die sich auch melden, dann müssen die noch da sein. Müssen ja auch kommen. Müssen zur Not abgeholt werden.
Und das beträfe ja dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch mal die großen Metropolen, die da derzeit noch weitgehend äh ausgespart äh wären. Das heißt, das Ganze wäre auch extrem unpopulär.
Weil ja eben auch die ganze Zeit das Ganze als Peace of Cake verkauft wurde. Ja hier Spezialoperation, Ukrainer und so, kein Problem.
Ein paar Tagen haben wir die. Das sind ja nur so ein paar Nazis. Ja, die ganzen Berichterstattungen passt ja überhaupt nicht zu dem Bild.
Nach dem Motto ja, jetzt kämpft er übrigens gerade die ganze Welt gegen uns. Jetzt müssen wir hier mal total äh Mobilmachung äh feiern.
Wobei die Propaganda schon so ein bisschen in die Richtung äh äh umgeschwenkt ist, aber ähm ja, aber offiziell ist es kein Krieg.
Sie bereiten hier und da vielleicht das Feld vor, aber es heißt ja nicht unbedingt, dass sie dann diesen Schritt auch gehen.
Ja, ich also ja, das ist jetzt natürlich wilde Spekulation.
Mhm. Ist immer der beste Teil hier im Podcast.
Ja, ja, ja. Ähm.
Also aus meinem, ich sage mal krimineller Psychopath, äh Psychogramm von Putin, äh wenn das zutrifft.
Äh wird der wird da eher den Schwanz einziehen. So äh wird da.
Das nicht tun, dann nicht mobil machen. Ja jetzt am neunten Mai ähm so äh sondern tatsächlich eher die Nummer fahren äh.
Dann ähm ja irgendwie einen Erfolg zu verkünden und Verhandlungen in in Aussicht äh zu stellen, wobei.
Er könnte auch einfach äh die zweite Möglichkeit wäre.
Spielt das Ganze weiter äh runter so, erwähnt das gar nicht großartig.
Ganze und äh das ist sogar ja die würde ich sogar für die wahrscheinlichste Variante halten.
Das äh es einfach so weitergeht wie bisher, mehr oder weniger. Ähm.
Und ähm ja, sich das Ganze nur allmählich verlangsamt,
und äh weil ja die Ukraine ist natürlich,
auch äh zwar nur äh wohl hat wohl im Schnitt nur halb bis ein Drittel so viele Verluste wie äh die.
Russen einfach weil sie eben in der Defensive agieren und weil sie vielleicht auch ein bisschen klüger
agieren, aber letztlich allein deswegen, weil die Ukrainer verteidigen und die Russen angreifen, haben die Russen natürlich zwei bis dreimal höhere Verluste so.
Und nur deswegen können können ja die Ukrainer in den Minderzahl im Moment auch auch mithalten, aber.
Ähm sie sind auch nicht stark genug jetzt die Ukraine
um äh das Blatt jetzt auf die Schnelle dann zu wenden und sie jetzt wirklich auch in kürzerer Zeit rauszudrängen. So.
Aber äh eigentlich.
Sieht für mich alles im Moment äh nach einem langen zähen Konflikt äh aus.
Eher an Intensität etwas abnehmen wird, weil einfach auch erst mal beide Seiten ähm wieder ähm ja.
Sich regenerieren müssen ähm und nicht in der Lage sind, diese Intensität äh einfach aufrechtzuerhalten, materiell nicht personell, äh nicht. Also das äh.
Das äh halte ich jetzt für für den.
Wahrscheinlichsten Verlauf äh im Moment.
Ähm ja, das ist das ist letztlich so weitergeht und.
Dann irgendwann vielleicht dann wieder an Intensität zunimmt, wenn dann äh beide Seiten wieder etwas aufmunitioniert äh haben.
Und ähm ja wenn das Ausmaß der.
Westlichen Waffenlieferungen, mhm das muss halt auch erst anlaufen und hochlaufen und ähm.
Klar, aber das läuft ja bereits.
So und es ist auch glaube ich for the long Run. Also es ist halt wirklich äh keiner macht sich die Illusionen, dass das schnell.
Beendet ist, sondern eigentlich ist es so, dass der Westen jetzt quasi in in so einen Kriegswirtschaftsbonus hochfährt.
Gut, im Moment ist es ja so, dass sie gucken äh erstmal hauptsächlich die ich sage mal Ostmunition und Ostsysteme, äh die im Westen irgendwo noch,
vorhanden waren da erstmal reingebracht haben, aber ähm da ist die Zahl
auch begrenzt. Ich glaube, die die Tschechen bauen, glaube ich, äh äh teilweise noch äh also es gibt gibt auch sozusagen neue noch neue Ostwaffen. Ich glaube
kannst auch irgendwelche Tee äh irgendwas äh äh Panzer auch noch neu von den Tschechen kaufen. Ähm.
Aber äh das sind halt auch nicht die die großen äh äh Kapazitäten. Das heißt, wenn man das jetzt langfristig betrachtet, äh wird man wahrscheinlich dann eher äh ja äh dann den sozusagen.
Den den Waffenbestand der Ukraine äh.
Durch andere Waffensysteme halt austauschen durch, ich sage mal dann also man wird die Ukraine natofizieren im Prinzip.
Aber natürlich ja genau das was Putin gewollt hat ja?
Ja.
Ja ich meine de facto ich meine jetzt kommen wir schon so ein bisschen auf die äh äh Debatte, die ich mir jetzt eigentlich so zum Schluss äh vorgestellt hatte, auch wenn das jetzt,
ein bisschen ist so, ne, aber es zeichnet sich ja ab.
Ja? Genau dieser Waffen äh Austausch führt ja im Prinzip dazu, dass quasi der
äh Waffenbestand und auch die Art und Weise sich für die Zukunft zu rüsten aus der Perspektive der Ukraine. Ich meine, es ist klar, dass die Ukraine ihr ihre Zukunft im Westen sieht,
Wollen jetzt in die EU und natürlich,
Würde ihnen nichts lieber sein als in der NATO zu sein, weil während sie in der NATO gewesen, hätte dieser Krieg so nicht stattgefunden.
Und äh dieses ganze Bild mit oh, wir dürfen aber jetzt hier irgendwie wir wir müssen ja hier neutrale Staaten haben an der Flanke Russlands, damit Russland nicht
Schlucke aufkriegt und auf einmal was Böses tut, das Ding ist jetzt auch durch. Ja, ich meine Finnland und Schweden ähm werden,
Relativ sicher, dass das jetzt einfach passieren wird, werden der NATO beitreten. Und ist jetzt auch gar nicht mal so, dass man da einen.
Land oder zwei Länder äh mit reinnimmt, die dann sozusagen auch nur Hilfe brauchen. Nein, Finnland hat einen extrem militarisiertes Land, wo,
alle äh gut ausgebildet sind, die äh entsprechende Reserven haben, Schwinden
nicht einschätzen, aber es zieht sicherlich auch nicht komplett anders. Ja, also die NATO wird enorm gestärkt durch diese beiden Länder, die dazukommen.
Man muss halt schauen, wie man jetzt mit mit diesen problematischen äh Teilnehmern hungern und Türkei in Zukunft noch umgehen möchte, aber immerhin sind sie halt Teil des Verbundes, was für uns jetzt erstmal auch kein kein Nachteil darstellt.
Es kann unmittelbaren Nachteil und äh letztlich denke ich mir halt, was kann.
Argumentativ eigentlich am Ende noch vorgebracht werden ähm wenn man sagt.
Leute, Ukraine ist jetzt sowieso.
Zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, wo dieser Krieg dann beendet ist, von von wovon ich ausgehe. Ja? Wird beendet sein irgendwann und er wird.
In einem Maße beendet worden sein, wo man sagen kann, Russland hat keinen Erfolg gehabt mit dem, was sie angestrebt haben und vor allem, man muss,
verhindern, dass dieser Konflikt weiter aufflammt und es wird leider nur durch so eine neue Konfrontation gehen können, die bedeutet, wir ziehen hier eine militärische Linie.
Die werdet ihr nicht überschreiten. Ihr werdet sie auch nicht erst mal nicht überschreiten können, weil ihr einfach euch selbst zu sehr geschwächt habt und wir sind überhaupt nicht bereit, dass das nochmal,
dahin kommt und deswegen ganz ehrlich sehe ich gar keinen Weg wie die Ukraine am Ende nicht.
In der NATO sein kann. Also sie wird.
So nah dran sein, wie vielleicht Finnland heute ist. Äh also de facto schon äh äh drin und vielleicht am Ende auch wirklich
konkret wirklich auch in der NATO, weil ich meine, welches Bedrohungsszenario will man jetzt noch ziehen, was nicht schon längst eingetreten ist?
Ja die die große Frage ist aber natürlich äh wie viel von der Ukraine, ja.
Ja gut.
So das ist äh und und darum äh geht's natürlich äh äh jetzt auch und auch noch mal
Jetzt was mich wegen den wegen den Waffenlieferungen, das erinnerte mich halt auch an an an covid äh äh.
So ein bisschen ähm weil äh oder wer zu spät kommt, den bestraft äh das Leben äh ist, in dem Fall halt äh dass,
was da ja jetzt ausgekämpft wird äh grade äh am am Boden militärisch ist ähm.
Ja, äh wie äh äh dann ähm am Ende äh einen Frieden
aussehen äh wird, so das heißt, da wird im Moment
quasi dann die Grundlage äh für den für den Frieden äh gelegt am Boden und dem kann man schon die Gleichung auch aufmachen äh je mehr Waffen und je schneller die Ukraine, umso mehr Waffen gibt
umso besser wird das Verhandlungsergebnis am Ende sein und je länger man äh oder je je weniger Waffen äh man liefert oder wenn man zu lange wartet. So äh ja
Ähm wird es halt ein weniger gutes Verhandlungs,
Ergebnis äh sein. So was dann ähm erstmal beim,
beim Waffenstillstand da sein wird und dann gibt's natürlich noch die große Frage, was ist mit der Krim?
Also im im Moment würde ich's eher so einschätzen, äh dass die äh Ukraine
Ähm diese unabhängigen Republiken, die sich da gegründet hat äh die will die Ukraine wiederhaben.
So
Komplett und im Grunde genommen ist, die sind ja jetzt auch komplett entvölkert worden, weil die Russen ja vor dem Angriff die gesamte Zivilbevölkerung äh.
Nach Russland da rausgeholt haben. Das heißt äh ja.
Ähm da gibt's jetzt in dem Sinne äh auch auch nicht das Problem, dass man da jetzt großartig wohl Zivilbevölkerung noch vertreiben müsste, russische.
Euch mal ja im Moment ähm.
Krimt meinst du?
Nee, äh im äh so Donbass und äh.
In den Ostgebieten auf der Krim. Die Krim hat Russland ja offiziell annektiert. Ja, das heißt, die betrachtet die Krim betrachtet Russland ja als eigenes Staatsgebiet.
Und äh da ist dann äh sagen eher die Frage ähm.
Okay was äh ist jetzt, wenn die wenn ähm.
Die Ukraine militärisch so viel Erfolg hat, äh dass sie auch dann in der Lage ist, äh die Krim anzugreifen, ja.
Und eventuell dort die Russen.
Äh Zufall äh auch von der Krim äh zu vertreiben. Das wäre dann äh sagen noch mal ein Eskalationspotential beziehungsweise das wäre dann möglicherweise ein Mobilmachungsgrund dann wiederum. Ja wenn
ja die Ukraine auf die auf die.
Vorrücken würde, weshalb Selenski ja auch schon relativ Anfang gesagt hat, na ja äh bei bei der Krim äh äh.
Können wir auch mal drüber äh nachdenken, dass wir erst mal sagen für fünfzig Jahre oder so oder für eine gewisse Zeit einfach mal äh ja ähm.
Den Status quo.
Da regieren lassen, das ist dann zwar, also wir erkennen das zwar nicht an, dass das euers ist, aber wir äh äh sagen versuchen euch da jetzt auch nicht militärisch zu vertreiben.
Ja da es darauf könnte es dann äh äh denke ich mal.
Hinauslaufen, aber das würde natürlich faktisch dann einen einen Verlust dann für Russland auch dieser äh autonomen Republiken äh äh quasi bedeuten, wobei.
Heißt Verlust. Äh der hat Putin ja.
Sehr viel äh Mühe äh äh drauf verwendet klarzustellen,
dass äh es sich um autonome Republiken handelt, dass sie nicht an Russland angegliedert werden. Da gab's ja diese,
Versammlung, wo er da seine ganzen Leute rund gemacht hat,
äh und unter anderem meine dann der Verteidigungsminister dann, ja, ich bin dafür, äh dass äh
die zu Russland dazukommen, weil nein, sie sollen nicht zu Russland dazu kommen, dass die Autonomen als autonome Republiken anerkannt werden.
Wusste hatten dann die eigenen Leute auch das Memo nicht gelesen. Insofern.
Gut, lass uns vielleicht mal zum äh Ende kommen, weil ich glaube, wir werden uns dann mal liebe
darauf konzentrieren dann in den nächsten Tagen äh nochmal Updates äh zu liefern, soweit haben wir jetzt glaube ich die Situation aus unserer Perspektive ganz gut zusammengefasst oder ob wir's gut zusammengefasst haben, das überlassen wir vielleicht mal.
Den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern, wir haben uns jetzt zumindest mal bemüht, mal so ein bisschen äh alles zusammenzufegen, was wir jetzt als äh das Wichtigste erachtet haben. Sind natürlich tausend
Aspekte und kleinere Meldungen, die man jetzt hier noch hätte, rein
stecken können, aber wir sind ja ja auch kein News-Podcast, sondern wir wollen ja einfach nur so ein bisschen unserem Gefühl einen Ausdruck geben und würde sagen ein Fazit kann man sagen.
Die Gesamtkriegssituation ist schlimm. Im Osten äh sterben einfach zu viele Leute die Situation in.
Ähm wie Maropol, Melitopol, et cetera, alles was äh Jazzson, alles was von den Russen komplett eingenommen wurde, lässt sich.
Nicht ermessen zu diesem Zeitpunkt und natürlich äh wird es weiterhin schwierig. Nur grundsätzlich denke ich zeichnet sich ab.
Kann diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen. Und jetzt muss man irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass sie ihn auch verlieren. Und verlieren heißt halt einfach, dass sie wieder dahin zurückkehren, wo sie vor Beginn dieser Aktion waren.
Im Detail ausgeht und was dann die Verhandlungsmasse ist und wer stärker dasteht,
unklar, wann das sein wird? Unklar, wer ähm welche Auswirkungen das auf Russland selber hat und insbesondere welche Verwerfungen das außenpolitisch und international politisch noch haben wird.
Lässt sich glaube ich derzeit überhaupt noch nicht äh absehen, hängt auch von sehr viel mehr Faktoren noch äh ab, die hier noch mit reinspielen, die man sowieso nicht unter Kontrolle hat oder wo er.
Uns auch gar nicht zu geäußert haben und nicht zu äußern wollen. Ja und dann werden wir das ähm weiterhin begleiten.
Ja vielleicht noch auch so ein Ding vielleicht ferne hoffnungsvolle Zukunft ähm
Es gibt natürlich auch ja schon dieses Wiederaufbaukomitee, ähm was jetzt schon dann plant ähm
die Ukraine wieder aufzubauen. Die ersten Schätzungen, was das kosten wird äh lagen äh bei,
20 Milliarden, das war aber schon vor vor Monaten, als der Krieg noch recht frisch war.
Mittlerweile geht man davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich eher in der Größenordnung äh fünfhundert,
Milliarden bis 1000 Milliarden kosten wird. Ähm wobei ich das,
noch für zu niedrig gegriffen, halte nimmt man jetzt das zum Beispiel Afghanistan,
Krieg der ganze Krieg gegen den Terror waren 3.500 Milliarden äh die der verschlungen hat. Gut, das war jetzt
auch die die die Kriegskosten und nicht nicht den Wiederaufbau aber ähm.
Was so die große Gefahr äh äh wäre, ist, dass wenn dieser Krieg.
Jetzt dann plötzlich oder ja zu Ende ist oder oder einen Waffenstillstand ähm
eintritt, ähm war so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass wir in anderen Kriegen oder Krisengebieten, nach denen das Kämpfen dann aufhört, dass äh dann dem wirtschaftlichen Aufbau halt,
zu wenig,
Aufmerksamkeit äh gewidmet wird und dass dann anschließend das Chaos oder die Situation wieder wieder aufflammt. Also ähm ja, ich ich.
Hoffe und glaube auch nicht, dass es in dem Fall so sein wird.
Aber die Gefahr sollte man natürlich im im Auge behalten. Ähm das sagen man dann nicht ein paar Jahre später eine eine neue Wiederauflage.
Äh wenn das jetzt in absehbarer Zeit äh unabsehbare Zeit zu Ende geht. Ich meine, wir könnten.
Daher vielleicht auch noch Schätzungen abgeben, wie lange denn das Ganze noch dauert, also wann wann wird's einen Waffenstillstand geben, was würdest du schätzen? Ich meine.
Sagen kann, dass natürlich niemand, aber so gefühlt.
Ich kann nur sagen, in welchem Zeitraum es auf jeden Fall nicht stattfinden wird und das sind die nächsten vier Wochen.
Also vielleicht sogar die nächsten zwei Monate.
Also wir haben ja also Afghanistan hat 20 Jahre gedauert äh bis wir verloren haben endgültig ähm ja.
Meine Hoffnung ist, dass dass der Konflikt der heiße Konflikt in diesem Jahr zum Erliegen kommt.
Meine Hoffnung ist, dass er morgen zum zur Liegen kommt, aber äh ich halte es, ich sage's mal so, für nicht.
Unrealistisch oder sagen wir mal, ich halte es für möglich. Aber das ist eine reine Gefühlssache, dass wir noch im Laufe der nächsten Monaten.
Tendenzen sehen werden, die in Richtung Schwächerung der russischen Position gehen, die dazu führen könnten, dass sozusagen.
Irgendwann Russland einsehen muss, dass sie das Ding nicht gewinnen können und dann auch das auf eine Art und Weise einsieht, dass sie anfangen müssen, sich Ausreden auszudenken, warum sie jetzt irgendwie diese Gebiete verlassen müssen.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, ich weiß aber nicht, ob das so sein wird, weil niemand weiß, welches
Eskalationspotential es noch gibt, sowohl im militärischer Hinsicht als auch in politischer Hinsicht. Meine Russland hat es bisher perfekt verstanden in den letzten zehn, 20 Jahren
äh den ganzen Westen irgendwie auf die Palme zu bringen,
Ich sehe sie hinter sowohl Tramswahl als auch hinter dem Brexit und äh man weiß nicht, wie viele Hebel hier noch im verborgenen schlummern, wie viel grobte
Politiker im Westen dieser ganzen Kampagne noch Knüppel zwischen die Beine schmeißen werden. Das das muss ich alles zeigen. Aber grundsätzlich.
Fände ich's äh absehbar, dass es auch in diesem Jahr zur Einstellen der Kriegshandlung kommen könnte.
Ja, ja. Ich meine, da ist allerdings auch die Einschätzung, dass Putin mit diesem Einmarsch ähm jetzt zwanzig Jahre.
Sehr geschickten Einsatz und Aufbau von Soft Power oder ja ich sage mal so einer äh so einem Ding zwischen hart und soft äh Power ähm.
Halt äh das das Spiel sehr gut gespielt hat aber ähm ja äh,
da ziemlich viel Arbeit und Investition äh ruiniert hat letztlich durch diese diese Invasion. Also.
Er hätte das geschickter spielen
können. So also eigentlich lief es für ihn ja äh zumindest was so dieser dieser ja hybride Krieg gegen den Westen angeht lief es für ihn äh wirklich gut äh.
Also gerade auch Deutschland und so hätte viele Freunde und viele Bewunderer äh auch im Westen und,
äh äh hat der da der großen Teil vor den Kopf gestoßen, außer ich weiß gar nicht, außer Gerhard Schröder.
Da fällt mir jetzt niemand ein so richtig, der noch äh irgendwie äh offiziell äh.
Was Positives über ihn sagt. Äh hast du noch sonst sonst irgendjemanden, der uns irgendeinen.
Der AfD jetzt nicht so zu, aber ich denke mal, da würden sich, dürften sich noch einige äh finden lassen.
Ja, okay, aber ansonsten äh so ist mir da nicht nicht viel aufgefallen.
Ja ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt grade sich da äh entsprechend zu positionieren. Aber ich meine das ähm
wie wir in diesem absurden, offenen Brief äh gesehen haben, der
von Alice Schwarzer und äh Anna Lunetics. Zu denen äh lustigerweise auch Ranger Juris war gehört äh veröffentlicht wurde. Also da äh musste ich dann doch schon mal meinen Hals zweimal wecken irgendwie. Ich dachte so bitte, hallo was, wie?
Aus meiner Perspektive ist es, dass so eine Haltung einfach nicht vermittelbar derzeit. Also es ist einfach dieses Ganze.
Oh wir müssen dürfen doch jetzt keine Waffen liefern und wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie mal ins Gespräch kommen das ist für mich.
Mit nichts unterfüttert
Also da weiß ich nicht so genau aus welcher Realitätswahrnehmung so eine Haltung abgeleitet werden kann. Das ist einfach auch,
der Ukraine nicht zu vermitteln und ich glaube auch einfach nicht, dass dass irgendeiner Form es auch nur den Ansatz irgendeiner Gesprächsbereitschaft gibt bei Russland hat sich ja schon gezeigt. Ist ja schon viel mit ihm geredet worden, aber das ist ja überhaupt nicht interessiert daran, irgendeine Verhandlung zu führen.
Und meine andere Sache ist, ja äh er wird.
Wird halt immer auch viel über na ja wir müssen ja auch eher auf die auf Deutschlands Interessen äh gucken und,
Deutschlands Interesse besteht natürlich äh auch darin ein gutes Verhältnis äh zu den Verbündeten und zu den Amerikanern äh zu bewahren, ja und äh zu den anderen europäischen,
Ländern und wenn äh wenn Deutschland äh sich da einfach ja als als Bremser äh äh.
Äh profiliert oder oder das Gefühl erweckt irgendwie sein äh nicht nicht das zu tragen
ähm so ähm nicht nicht seinen Anteil, nicht kein kein fairen Anteil zu tragen, ähm dann ja ist das nicht gut für Deutschland, ja ganz egoistisch. So.
Ja und wir sollten natürlich ein Interesse daran haben, einfach hier wieder zu friedlichen ähm äh Situationen zu kommen und die kommen wir sicherlich nicht durch so eine äh Politik und irgendwie Russlandversteherei, das ist einfach echt vorbei.
Vor allen Dingen äh haben wir das ja schon ausprobiert. Das hat ja nicht funktioniert.
Das müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal, also wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal was ausprobieren, äh was wir schon mal ausprobiert haben und was halt äh ja nicht erfolgreich war.
Gut Pable, lass es uns äh damit ähm beenden heute.
Vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören an alle und äh wir melden uns bald wieder. Ich äh gebe jetzt mal noch keinen Zeitrahmen raus. Wir haben ja noch ein paar andere äh Dinge, die erstmal erledigt werden müssen, aber wir kommen wieder und.
Mal wieder mit euch. Also.
Jo, macht's gut, bis denn, tschau.